Yeah.
Hey fuckers.
Can we go again?
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by taking a,
if you've never been to tink before
and you don't know what Tang is.
One of the things that we like about a
company and like Tang is that we'd like
companies that are trying to be ethical,
trying to not fuck people over and like
that's like a part of their ethic that's
like the what,
what they're trying to accomplish in
business is not just to make money,
but to have a company that is like,
it's fair.
And one of the cool things that
tain does is they have no contracts.
I love that they're on
the sprints backbone.
I love that.
So it's like,
you know,
you get good service,
you get a big name company behind it is
a giant national company and it's the
backbone that you're on
and you get to bodies.
Awesome.
Android phones are like top of the line,
android phones and you can
cancel anytime you want.
You can have you and
your wife on an account,
although I don't think that's it.
That's not going to,
yeah,
know that's kind of a bitch.
Middle.
Yeah.
You share minutes.
I mean,
you can,
it's,
it's a really,
uh,
it's really cool setup.
The way it works.
If you don't use a
certain amount of minutes,
like if you're,
you know,
you assign yourself off for one program,
but it turns out that you actually only
use the amount of minutes would be in a
lower program.
They just send you the money back.
They,
they,
they hook you up on the next bill.
It's like the way they do it.
It's so cool.
That's why we don't have it in England.
That's why not in England
do you get fucked?
We got fucked.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's
because we're an island,
so we're separated.
So your cell phones are more expensive.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
Because someone has to
set up the infrastructure,
right?
Everything's more expensive.
Well,
that they have here at Tang,
they have something called a sprint.
Err,
err,
rave.
And what it is,
it's a plugs into your internet at your
house and it makes your own cell phone
tower in your house because
they're usually at your house.
And if you don't have good cell phone
network around your house and blows.
So what this does is it pretty much makes
your own cell phone tower out of your
house.
So you always have good service.
That's amazing.
So that would have the internet.
Yeah.
So 10 actually has this right now.
Uh,
it's four to 54,
which is really good.
We need cell phone service at your house.
That's important.
And if you go to Rogan,
[inaudible]
dot com you'll save 25 bucks off
of either service or you know,
or the phone.
Um,
you could,
you could use it in,
in any way you like.
And like I said,
we have,
they have the top of the line,
android mobile phones,
like Samsung Galaxy s three,
the Samsung Galaxy note to,
have you seen that thing?
Oh my God,
I gotta get one of those.
I keep talking about it.
I just don't have the time.
James Thompson to go out there and get
one of them bitches look good with Matt.
Yeah,
I've met,
I would have to have a bum bag.
Right.
I have mad a screen envy when
it comes to those things.
Anyway,
go to rogan.ting.com and
save yourself some money.
Yo a little fuckers.
Uh,
we are also brought to you by audible.com
and if you go to audible.com forward
slash Joe,
you will get one free month of their
awesome service and you will also get one
free audio book.
You know,
one of the cool things about audible's,
first of all,
they've been around a long time.
Audible used to do stuff with
comedians like way back in the day,
I want to say like 2001 ish when they
were releasing like they got guys like,
I know Steve Marmel did it and I know
a few other guys were doing it as well,
where they would do like a
new five minutes every week
and they would release it
on audible.
It's kind of a tough sell.
But they tried,
you know,
they,
they gave him the shot.
They have some balls and uh,
I appreciate that they did that.
I don't know if they
still do that anymore.
I probably shouldn't say they tried.
Maybe that's like a big feature,
but,
um,
I'm a big fan of the
audio book format and uh,
the disaster diaries,
um,
which was Sam Sheridan's book,
the guy who was just here
yesterday is available.
That's what I would recommend.
If you want to get a new book,
it's to check checkout.
It's a fascinating,
fascinating book.
And it's read by some other dude,
but some dude named Donald Korn and I'm
sure Donald did a good job and all that.
I'm not saying he's not,
but why wouldn't you have Sam,
Sarah at Sheridan Read Sam
Sheridan's fucking book.
Maybe this is Sam's partner.
No,
I think it's like,
you know,
probably the book company.
It was like,
I think we should get an actor.
I mean,
listen,
Sam,
he rode a captivating speaker,
but we need that extra professional touch
to really push your audio book to the
top of the charts.
And sound was like,
all right,
I think it's more likely that,
right?
I,
yeah,
I think so.
I would recommend that opie and Anthony,
uh,
audible book last week,
they had the gay off episode.
Uh,
so they have the opening
Anthony show there.
What is it?
Yeah,
but so is there a name of that?
The gay off episodes
where people can specific
it?
Search for it actually called,
uh,
the gay off and it's February 13th,
2013 with Andrew dice clay
and they have it on audible.
And I believe each episode you
can either do a subscription,
so you always get the Ogun
Anthony show or you get a,
if you sign up through your thing,
you get a,
I think a free audible book.
Don't,
you should get one free audio book so
you can just get it free right now.
Just sign up right now.
Get this one episode and laugh
your fucking ass off and cringe.
And,
and,
and by the way,
just a massive amount of books
that you can choose from.
It's a,
it's an awesome service.
One of the cool things they have is a,
an application for,
um,
the Amazon kindle and the kindle fire HD.
And what it is,
is the,
the audible whisper sync application.
What it does is if you're
reading a book at night,
so you'd be stopped on page 300.
When you get in your car,
it's syncs up and starts the audio
version of the book you're reading.
It's fucking fantastic.
It's a brilliant idea.
It's like one of the,
one of the coolest things
for like driving it driving
actually.
Interesting.
So a go to audible.com
go and check that out.
We were also brought to you
by on it as we are every week.
O,
n n I t.
Um,
we have a,
a new testosterone supplement.
James Thompson,
you might be interested in that if
you're looking to get extra swole.
I don't think he needs a hope.
You're in to get an extra swole.
Now you,
uh,
you actually lost weight,
right?
You were a little bit
bigger at one point in time.
I've been up and down all the time.
Yeah.
Do you like try to figure out like
what feels like where you're at your
strongest?
Where?
Yay.
Is it like a sacrifice thing?
When it,
let me get through this commercial.
We'll get to that because it was like,
I have a lot of fucking
questions for you man.
Anyway,
on the.com use the code name Brogan,
save 10% of any and all supplements.
We've got a lot of cool shit.
It's too cold.
You what's happening?
What's it called?
This testosterone.
It's called t plus.
It's got 'em all sorts of natural shit.
Mucuna Purina's it helps elevate natural
dopamine levels and magnesium is ferric
acid.
It was just some,
uh,
it's a supplement that's shown him one
test to increase free testosterone by
42%.
So it's called,
it's got magnesium and yeah.
Well yeah,
that's one of them.
Yeah.
It's one of the ingredients.
You know,
we were talking about the zinc,
magnesium supplement,
that CNA stuff,
which is a very good for you and
it can increase testosterone.
But apparently what they're saying
is it increases it in people who are
deficient in zinc,
which is most of us apparently.
Yeah.
Apparently most people
aren't getting enough zinc.
I do it almost five times a week now.
You make it does make me feel better,
right?
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of zinc.
I think there's something
in that net Zma uh,
that's uh,
an interesting supplement and one of the
things is also they think it helps you
recover better and build your testosterone
more because you're getting more
sleep.
Yeah.
Like a deeper sleep.
You go to like that the deepest level of
sleep usually don't get too addicted to
it.
Do you think like with them I see him,
I just know like if I'm
traveling or if I'm like,
you know what,
I need to go to sleep and I'm not tired.
I'll just play on the Internet all day.
I'll just take it like offering it up.
You were offering it at all?
I would like this kids is EMA free fruit.
Zma like crazy.
I go love is something you
really needed in your diet.
Yeah,
definitely.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Obviously that's so basically he's,
he's worked.
Yeah.
I think a lot of us
are deficient and shit.
We just don't realize it man.
But he didn't get cramps
in their potassium.
Apparently it was why you get cramps?
I get cramps,
you know,
sleep and you wake up screaming
because he accidentally got it.
Gives a Charlie horse in the middle
of the night from dehydration.
Probably you're an unhealthy
fucking charley houses.
You don't know what Charlie Horses,
um,
Charlie horses when like
something like stiffens up on you.
There's two different ways that like some
people called Charlie who is a punch,
like a punch in the shoulder or
punching a leg that it means something
completely different.
But England,
is that what they call a Charley horse?
No,
we've got like pumped
in the almond England.
Yeah.
What does that pumped down?
Did just call punched in the arm.
That's probably a better
way of dealing with why.
Why would the silly fucking nicknames
and have to relearn how many halls?
Slug bug is what it's called.
The United States beetle.
A Volkswagen.
Yeah.
He told me about this.
I didn't know this existed.
There's a lot of people in the
country and this country in America,
Mr. Thompson,
they're just looking for an
excuse to hit each other.
So they'd come up with
games where it's friends
fucking asshole.
We're a country of assholes
on it.com not assholes.
Go use the code rogue and saved 10% go
get yourself a Blendtec blender and some
fucking kettlebells so you could
be manly like James Thompson.
All right,
we're here.
We're queer.
Get used to it.
Started to roll the podcast
experience.
Powerful.
James Thompson.
Welcome aboard,
sir.
Thank you very much for coming on,
man.
I was very excited to talk to you.
I know,
I know.
It's going to be fun because,
uh,
you're,
you're a character that
I've enjoyed for many,
many years in the world
of mixed martial arts.
I remember the first fight that you had
with Alexander Milliken Aiko and pride
when you came,
I don't remember.
You went bananas,
man.
You took it to 100 miles an hour from
the moment the bell rang and you just red
line that bitch.
And you know,
it didn't,
I mean it was a crazy fight,
but you don't eat.
When that fight happened,
you'd only been doing martial arts
training for a shorter amount of time.
Right.
Doing it for a year.
Now
I know I worked,
I was,
um,
I didn't do anything before pop foam.
Um,
before my first fight,
I had a platform,
I don't know,
six months veselin good wrestling.
And then I saw,
I may put myself in for a contest six
weeks later and I thought to myself,
we're doing,
I wasn't,
it wasn't like a camp.
It was a class three times a
week and that did other things.
I'm self different,
cardio,
different this,
different that.
So that's what I did.
I made it,
put it all together,
did my class of MMA,
and then,
uh,
after like three,
four weeks of hot,
I'm ready for a fight.
Not because I'm,
I would again,
or just yourself.
Well,
I just fault I didn't realize
how much the words to it.
Uh,
I didn't get how deep it was.
Like looking at it from the outside.
That's doing a little bit simple.
Yeah.
Well,
you're a huge guy.
Yeah.
So your whole life,
you've been a huge guy,
I'm sure.
So you probably not used to being
around you were smaller and smaller,
if that makes sense.
But you know like so your,
your,
your look at the sport of MMA was probably
not from even as from a position of
like,
why don't I fucking do this?
Like I'm designed for this shit.
Well I can kind of,
because
I always wonder why
didn't I know do boxing
right.
Why didn't you,
what did you do?
Okay.
It looks like you picked
up a lot of heavy shit.
Did you do that video game?
I would look in back home in a
flashback to be molested or something.
Like I was going to stop
breaking down in tears,
you know,
if we can all know what if I opened there?
What sports did you do?
Book pay.
I was very good at rugby.
Rugby in my opinion,
sacrilege.
People will say sacrilege.
It's just inherently more
badass than football.
There's no question.
This put this pad thing is ridiculous
and I know we've accepted it.
Pads.
They were the football players,
the pads and helmets and shit.
Oh,
American football,
American football.
Not Soccer,
soccer obviously,
but American footballs,
the idea is ridiculous.
Pad yourself up and running each other.
Full clip rugby.
To me it's like you got like a
little leather thing in your head,
but
sometimes it protects
your ears for falling off,
so don't go fuck fucking call it.
It's just more bad ass.
It seems like a more bad ass port,
you know?
I think different ways like
Vulckbie it's fucking tough.
I don't know if some people,
some guys off,
you know,
professional fighters and then
obviously doing over things.
I'm voc bop.
One of them I'll tell you.
Oh yeah,
I had a book.
Maybe you play vogue behind you fight.
Wow.
Fuck you got an injury,
so get people step on you.
Oh yeah.
Fuck.
When you go on the train
and they got the heels on,
they,
oh yeah.
When I,
when I first started playing,
I couldn't believe it.
I was getting stumped.
Telephone.
What are you fucking stump him in?
I ended up popping a fight on the,
okay,
no pub in a fight on the pitch.
It's really common to have fights
in rugby isn't very common,
which is so cool cause stumping.
Yeah,
it's so close to a fight.
It's like three quarters of a fight,
you know,
and you get into the scrubs.
It's like three quarters
of a fight going on.
It's amazing that it's not
like a constant length.
I didn't do it in a war.
Well,
I mean I,
you know,
I've,
I've enjoyed football games before.
It's not that I don't get the appeal
of watching a great football player.
I absolutely do.
But I'm like,
I would love to see those
athletes play rugby.
I would love to see what would happen.
It would be like a band and football.
I think it's fun to watch.
It's craziness,
man.
Yeah.
Posh people do it.
Posh people in England.
I love that word,
by the way,
Steven fucking great way
of describing things.
Such a few words.
I've really like,
it started to appreciate
Larry like proper,
that's a proper car.
You know,
proper is a,
that's a Badass.
A Batoche what?
Posh is another one.
I like posh posh.
Then sometimes you fit out popper posh.
Oh,
proper posture is gangster,
right?
Yeah.
That's when you go over to someone's
house and they got a peacock.
Shit's proper.
Posh dudes have like fucking
statutes themselves and
the fountain and there are a Merman.
You know,
you ever seen those guys?
I know a couple that has a fucking
where he's a Merman and she's a mermaid.
Oh there is.
He,
he's a super duper billionaire.
He has a statues of her.
He created a statue of her in a fountain.
Wow.
Yeah,
he had,
he has this,
she's very pretty and you know,
you've got to guess.
He's like super psyched.
Gets to fucker.
Anyways,
these paintings all over the place of
the two of them and one that's a Merman
and
guy in England.
Okay.
You know,
locked talk,
stock,
gangster block.
Um,
I can't remember what it was called.
Anyway,
he um,
I just got on the side of his house,
him as king,
gaffer on a halls with,
he's wide,
you know,
the spear
book.
Do you know he's not inside his house.
He's not inside his house.
It's fucking outside his house.
Same.
So everyone can see it.
He can't even fucking see it.
You can see it.
So they just sticking his
dick out of his front yard.
Oh,
what am I crazy ass Stacie's deck.
Oh my God.
I forget I'm an east deck.
No,
but I'm saying,
you know,
that's what he's doing by having that,
oh like him as a famous French
fucking deep into to Dick thing.
Yeah.
Bozeman to been a big thing.
Yeah,
that is for sure.
You know crazy ass hall
people are so nuts,
man.
It's pretty well known.
Just kind of like we slept together.
You remember when Lean Mary had that
mural made of him wrangling Jorge Rivera.
That's what I was going to mention.
But cause I know Leah novel,
I love that guy.
He's a character.
I know he's a criminal and all that
jazz and he's done a lot of bad things.
I understand.
I mean,
I wouldn't want to be on his bad side,
that's for sure.
But he's so entertaining,
so crazy.
He's,
I mean I,
he trained up London.
Shoot while you still trained.
I started training the chill stuff to,
he laughed.
But I did do a,
um,
like a game,
a video game,
cute with him and it was just off
to being stopped on eat coming up.
They'll spot,
he was vague.
Finn Looking,
you know,
I'm used to say name like
everyone else at events,
you know,
event or not.
He always calls,
you know quite no,
not mostly about lean and I'm healthy.
I know when I saw him he just vaguely,
they drone on fucking owl.
I'm not to what he lives everyday,
you know,
that kind of shit.
Getting stopped shooting like
literally some of stores and you know,
go over the top and
people get carried away,
especially in Italian gangster stories.
But there was some from so many good
people who I know who were there and
they're like fucking owl valley.
Like,
like
I mean massive fights.
Fucking punching through a car window
found out about and because of its treat,
vote with tea or allegedly,
no,
Tito has one version of it
and Pat Miletich and the
other guys that were there
have another version of it.
But the bottom line was somehow
they've gotten some sort of a fight.
I don't believe too,
I could never say it wasn't there,
but
I wasn't that I actually started it.
I didn't,
I'm just saying.
But um,
he was a part allegedly of a lot
of people don't know the story.
The biggest bank robbery
in the history of England,
right?
Yeah.
No,
no,
that is fucking crazy.
If you look at the security cam footage,
it's like you looking at us,
the rest are stolen movie and I get done.
Even like a Guy Ritchie movie,
it's like it's not,
this is not,
this can't be real.
They can't be dressed with ski goggles
on and commando outfits and machine guns
and they can't be really robbing
a bank cause this is just bananas.
When they did it,
it was a bank upon it,
which I thought more show too.
I'm the reason why they didn't,
I thought more secure security.
So no one knows what it is.
Like it takes a blank building with,
obviously he's going to be fucking secure,
but ultimately,
oh cause they don't want
to talk to tension to it.
So that's why they think
Kenny's got be an inside job,
which you kind of look up anyway.
I think a lot of that stuff
is probably inside job.
If you're making 50 grand a year and
you're working in a place like that,
you know how much does
that fuck with your head?
Imagine you can see that money
going back and forth every day.
La,
you're just standing there watching it
and you're just a banker and you're a
banker and you're like,
how do I ever get rich as I can
eat right and falling on my face?
And you got a crazy cousin.
He'd tell that crazy cousin
when you're drinking.
Who knows?
Would be a way we can rob it.
I mean,
and we shouldn't rob it,
but next thing he knows it and you
cousin starts spreading out the math and
you're smoking meth with
him and you're like,
we're gonna rob this guy.
Let's go fucking math.
Yeah,
those are,
those are a rock salt because
it's like it's somehow or another,
it's supposed to give off good energy.
I don't know if that's horse shit or not,
but I'm going to go Melissa Etheridge
on this bitch and just sewed shipped it.
It is,
it is salt,
but it's kind of cool.
But whenever I talk about him
a couple months,
maybe a month or so,
do you feel much goodwill?
I'm not sure.
Pretty Thompson.
I don't know if that's,
I don't know if it's the rocks.
That's the problem with,
uh,
a lot of different things.
It's like how much of
it is a placebo effect?
Why does a fucking placebo effect work?
That's,
well,
that's a weird thing,
man.
Why does that work?
Because you believe it.
Yeah,
but why does it actually work sometimes?
Because you believe it.
I know,
but scientifically what the fuck is going
on with your mind that your mind can
take a pill and think
it does something good?
So all of a sudden it
does do something good.
I mean,
that is a amazing property
of the human body is,
um,
I'm,
this is what I'm saying.
If you,
if you believe it,
if you,
Oh,
I've gone all Murphy average.
The fucking,
you've touched with the
crystals and the power source.
Thomson.
Just go with your feelings
when I'm express yourself.
Express yourself.
No,
I,
when I listened to that podcast,
I know I,
for me,
she's quite hippie.
Melissa Etheridge,
she was awesome.
Beautiful Person.
I,
I sold much of what she said.
I was like,
yes,
she's had,
she's had the secret.
It's like the fuck.
Like she liked it,
which are the,
it's like the fast food of positive
thinking and all that easy fix.
And I thought what a great
way to sum it all up.
Yeah.
I don't know if she's right about her.
Her idea was that you sort of
manifest reality from your own mind,
your imagination.
But she might be right.
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't necessarily believe it,
but I know this,
believe it either.
I think it's an interesting possibility
to consider or it might be a combination
of,
you know,
random events and how much you guide
it with your own thoughts and their own
mind.
The phone.
Well,
I don't think anyone does and that's fair.
I was listening to her.
I was like,
wow.
Yeah,
I'm not green,
but scene where she's coming from and yet,
okay,
wow.
And a lot of it and then,
but it seemed a bit too definite
like that that's the way it is.
And she would say,
I think that's the way east to her.
Yeah.
So therefore it's so,
well I also think she would say
it's very self serving to be,
I mean self serving in a positive way
to be definite because if you want to
believe in something,
like if you want to really
you have to believe in 100% for it to
work home didn't have a placebo effect
where actually I think that's not true.
I think there's been a study that showed
that they did give people placebos and
tell them there was a placebo.
It's still have a measurable effect.
Uh,
some pill that they gave him,
like they knew the whole time,
it was just a fake pill,
but it's still works.
And I think those are like the same
people that you could hypnotize.
You know,
there's some,
you can hypnotize everyone.
Everybody,
everybody 100%.
You can hypnotize them
as long as I relaxed.
So you would say,
well,
you weren't relaxed because
I'm going to hit a to you now.
You would definitely tend to up.
I haven't.
No.
You know,
I talked to a guy who can assist and he
said that some people you can hypnotize
you,
but that was his word because they won't
let themselves to relax that you treat
as a stat.
I don't think I would ever
let anybody run my thoughts.
Exactly.
It's not that I wouldn't,
it's not that I wouldn't relax.
I'm absolutely,
I could absolutely relaxed,
but I would.
I'm not really into letting
other people run that,
getting sleeping.
No.
I know what I'm getting done.
All the,
I'm really relaxed.
You're not going into my head.
I think that the guy was
hypnotizing you is dumber than you.
Right.
There's no way,
mother fucker,
there's no way you can
it up with some shit.
That's what I see.
I thought I'd looked.
See Devin down prone on it.
You Watch it.
Shit.
I know.
I've heard of them.
Oh mate,
is he hit me this as well.
He's a magician.
No,
no,
no.
Eat,
no,
no.
It's in between these kind of like,
hey,
this ball.
Yeah,
just to do super trickster.
he,
yeah,
he's a super quick story
is he told us some of it.
He says,
this is why it's a trick.
[inaudible] had explained
why it's this and that.
I'm white.
I'm the only one he didn't get right.
And this where I really me to,
to the guy fucking going to go to the
bank and got him to get tank vanned out
of,
out of its own account.
Then he said to him,
he got this guy by random and then you
took him to a roulette finger and he
said,
right,
I'm going to get you on the old,
the guys watching on the screen,
and he said,
I don't want to get your money.
I'm going to put it on one number.
If it loses,
it loses.
If it wins,
the money's yours.
So the guy was like,
I need something.
They showed him the video of him,
hypnotize him and that he was his money.
Right.
So there's that.
So you've seen that and he's been stood
in the fucking spins and toughness fall
and doing all this stuff
leading up to it anyway,
when it comes to it,
gets it fucking wrong,
gets it fucking wrong.
And he gets every eat and then before
that he protected the lot of the numbers.
All six of them do.
I'm obviously,
he said that it was a trick.
I'll raise it at the end.
It was a little bit,
now it's a trek garbage truck.
Yeah.
That's why I love Penn and teller.
They tell you what the fuck the trends.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but down,
down by and leaves it.
So,
so with the lottery thing,
I like that because it's like that
shows when it comes to like lady luck,
well fuck you to do.
I mean do you not think you're
getting one over on lady luck,
slap you down.
That's the big issue that
people have with psychics.
Like if you really were psyche,
when you win every lottery,
like what are you doing?
He can make a lot of
money playing the lottery.
Imagine if you won the lottery like
every week and everybody be like,
Hey asshole,
the fuck are you doing?
Yeah.
Like dude,
I'm excited.
Yeah.
I wonder,
I wonder how many times we'd want it
before you got born than you do something
else.
Well,
Vegas won't let you win
that many times in a row.
Like Vegas.
We'll kick you out of casinos.
Even if you're not doing anything illegal.
Like David Cho,
he's been kicked out of casinos.
Like he's just too smart.
They're like,
you gotta get out here.
You're fuck you thinking too much and
you've got a system and it works too.
Well,
they won't say that to me.
They won't sell it to you
or say won't kick you out.
Why does that cause you to vague?
Nope.
Because I'm giving them lots of money.
You've given them lots of money.
Yeah,
because I'm,
because I started giving them them.
Well,
if you started winning,
no man,
no fucking deadline.
But uh,
you've had a gambling
problem.
That's what you're trying to say.
Yeah.
You know,
that'd be trying to foam here.
I've got my money to give you,
fuck,
I'm not finished leaves in.
Why do you get crazy and gamble some much?
I don't know.
That's like a question.
It's not question everyone asks us.
No,
no one else didn't.
I think ask yourself,
you know why?
And I don't know that we've not,
I'm not copping out here.
I'm thinking maybe some part genetic
all my fault about the source.
Yeah.
But my,
my,
my father,
my dad,
well my dad had a camber governor.
No problem.
Do you have a proper gambling problem?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Pauper Porsche gambling.
So he was a,
and you saw this when you were growing up,
but,
no,
I never,
I never met my dad.
Oh yeah.
The first time I never met him.
I do know all,
I never even fought by him
cause my mom was that good.
Well that's amazing man.
I'm fucking it when you think of it,
because there's was a,
you know,
when she met my dad it was,
um,
you know,
I was like,
I remember,
you know,
timeline,
we'll talk came over and uh,
and this and that.
Um,
because just want eight.
You just cut out.
I wanted that father figure I suppose.
But um,
yeah,
what was the first time I found out?
But that was,
dad was,
my mom came to the door
and you know that vein,
which is polite.
And um,
then then,
then I said to a,
um,
that she,
that she said to me,
because I didn't know
yet and she said to me,
your Dad's dad and
I'm not and that was it.
Um,
and then she told me about
the funeral and we went to,
um,
she picked me up,
went to the funeral,
I'm having a coffee and she took talk
about it and then we were laughing after
five minutes just because
there's nowhere really that sad.
No,
he didn't have a big place in your life.
I'm sure I met,
met him right when he had a
gambling problem is your point.
Yeah.
And so you feel like it's probably
genetic that you have one as well?
Fuck it out.
Fucking owl to dungeon.
I felt we were fucking talking about,
yeah,
we were talking about the gambling.
So do you like,
like what is it like you get in casinos
and you just can't help yourself.
You just started playing card.
What do you play?
Blackjack and talk about the fucking yeah.
Blackjack tattooed on your
arm going up in flames.
Wow.
And then I've got a
positive affirming message.
What does it say?
I'll find strength in pain.
[inaudible] you got cards
on fire on your arm.
I got some goofy tattoos too.
It's okay.
I don't think,
I don't think of it as beef.
Mine means waterfalls.
Yeah.
He thought it was
forgotten.
A woman friend who is learning
how to tattoo if you want to.
If you're on a really awful,
awful,
what does that,
I've got the serenity prayer.
Well there's
our,
that's not funny.
I think a,
this is actually kind of interesting.
They see the funny bit there.
The dates.
What crossed out the dates across.
Crossed out.
Yeah.
Cause that,
that was the last time we gambled.
Gambled.
Took what?
The costs out.
Oh Wow.
And then you make another one and
then I'm gonna run out of room son.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
well I did run out of it because,
so every time you've gone you're wow.
So that's your biggest issue is gambling.
Oh,
has this,
uh,
how,
how long has this
existed for in your life?
For years.
Kindof five.
Really?
That's when he started
gambling like crazy.
Yeah.
Well that's when I just,
excuse me.
Do you know that,
um,
there's,
there's a study that recently came
out that said that there might be a
connection between,
uh,
gambling addictions and brain damage.
Is that yeah.
And burn probably fucking good.
Good tests come to that far.
Yeah.
He might be,
man,
I think he's sent in or something.
No,
I'm not hearing the same thing,
but it was a,
uh,
a recent study I would have
to tell you about this.
I mean,
if I'd had known,
but this,
I'm actually,
it wasn't that recent.
It was like 2003,
but that brain damage,
that addictive behavior,
they believe that there's a,
there's a connection between guys
who have suffered him and impacts,
and obviously you're very functional.
It's not like I'm saying
that you got brain damage,
but everybody's been hitting the head
has a certain amount of brain damage.
I'm sure I have brain damage,
but this,
that this was a,
a connection between that
and pathological gamblers.
You know,
that's a,
that's a fascinating connection.
Well,
I started thinking God food,
listening to your show all,
all the time.
Um,
I,
I'm having about the football players
and the kind of concussions and things
like that.
Um,
even about the depression now,
I was going through about being
for vague about depression.
Um,
I,
I wanted it thought,
been not touched how many times
getting concussions and such forth.
I drug problems I've had.
Um,
I was,
I didn't pop in with Ghb,
which is stuff that makes you sleep.
Yeah.
I had a problem with that and I,
it's not,
not excuses.
It,
um,
you know,
because it's smelt like,
oh yeah,
that's why I got not take loads.
I've got shit defense and you know,
my,
I'm not,
not quick standup.
Okay.
But on top of that,
taking that out and say it's a mental
attitude of not concentrate into training
as an effect.
Well,
did you,
um,
take,
it seems like you took fighting like
less seriously then than you do now.
When you,
when you first started,
did you not understand the consequences?
Was it,
was it a matter of that
and how is it a matter of,
it just became like something
where you just really decided,
I got to get dedicated if
I want to keep doing this.
I took
it seriously.
I like,
I it on your way to do it.
I went to Mitchell,
just jumped right in the prime cause that,
well because it was
just the way it was the,
I've been thinking about this now to me.
I went,
I saw it,
I can do that.
I did it right.
I kind of believed it and I saw the
fight in and I saw nog and I fought.
I'm not too far off after his
fucking unbelievably fucking naive.
And then I went in on,
I had my first fight,
I could do it and I thought,
yeah,
okay,
I can do this.
Um,
and then 10 shows later,
I mean,
the main event against done seven loads
of people are fucking watching me and
I'm,
I'm just,
I'm out and a new way at the time.
A lot of time going to the first event.
I said to my girlfriend at the time,
I'll be main event and I'm not like that,
but I said it and I just knew it until,
because I believed it
happened because I made it up.
But also because you're
gigantic and you worked out.
Oh yeah.
That made it happen.
Nobody.
Okay.
There's like a few,
uh,
didn't work out.
Don't know.
I,
I was working out because
I was training to,
so I was trying to hard
for if that's right,
but um,
I have in them before,
so I was relatively fit,
but no,
but that's the,
you mean you jumped into the
deep end of the pool right away?
Yeah,
I did.
Yeah.
That's pretty,
I mean,
you fought Alexander Emelianenko who's
a high level MMA heavyweight within how
many months of use?
Beginning training and striking,
uh,
fight for about a year.
Just over a year.
So,
but I wasn't training,
I didn't have a team that I was telling
him the little dove or that and it was
all a bit,
that's what they said.
What happens then?
You know,
you know,
you go and get little chills right now.
I'm ready.
I know.
And I remember watching him and I and Co
and it looked like on a video and just
like not in the flesh again.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
Myself,
I was like,
yeah,
I can do this.
Okay,
okay,
I can do that.
That was a crazy fight,
dude.
Okay.
That was a crazy fight.
You just charge after that.
But what you saw though
was me being serious as it.
So to me that was authentic rage.
That wasn't obviously my video.
I explain it and
we'll make a lot of videos now.
And you're,
yeah,
I'm loving to hell.
Blogs and stuff and putting them online.
No,
I've,
I've really enjoyed it.
I've been lucky enough,
I've got,
um,
I,
I met Guy,
I'm sigh,
it's like Paris and he
dive accent does a film.
I told him about a few ideas.
He came down,
started doing these,
putting these ideas into play and yeah,
it's going really well.
That's cool man.
So this um,
this colossal concerns,
things that you're doing,
all these videos and the blogs and
everything and it seems like you're really
excited about this.
Like you constantly tweeting,
tell everybody or we retweet
shit pending the asthma.
It little bit of pain in the ass about it.
But I appreciate
the,
I like what you're doing.
I like very enthusiastic
about that 12 take,
I'll take,
that's a bit annoying,
but then it doesn't annoy me.
No,
but it annoys other people.
I don't mind.
It doesn't bother me.
I just get scared.
I'm trying to make me scared.
I told him I'll pay,
people are asking me to retweet shit.
It's normal for me.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's the thing.
Like I think the,
in the future that's what will be the red.
Um,
that's what he said in the,
in the future it'll be
likes will be currency.
Currency.
I used trig.
Yeah.
I really think that that would
be the best way to live the life.
Live world,
the world.
You know,
if you could actually
work it out that way.
So like being nice and helping people
would give you the most currency,
that would be the most beautiful.
But what about the simple,
no,
can't be that simple.
We're not living in a garden.
Know I've seen people who
loved hot kit that people,
they'd be,
they'd be all that kind of
fucking bullshit going on.
Wacky coder or son of a bitch would get
in there and exert his intelligence,
troll dominance over that computer and
fucking whack it out and have a billion
likes.
You have more likes than there are people.
Every one socket I cracked the code bed.
Yeah,
that's a,
it's a,
that's a beautiful idea.
But they've got to figure out something
better than letting old people just keep
it and make everybody else
paying interest on it.
And the Federal Bank and all this,
you see all these big giant banks.
It's supposedly control these different
aspects of our political systems,
yours and ours.
Did you see the,
um,
let me go,
what off of the federal reserves,
like a partial bit of it got printed
and it was trillions of dollars.
Trillions going to
different bunks all over.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
The secret hidden,
uh,
bail outs that we didn't know
about millions of dollars.
He's a crazy,
it's,
it's robbery right in front of your face.
She belt on my fall.
Trillions.
What do you get back?
Justifiable robbery.
That's what it is.
They figured out how to,
how to like Jack,
this system,
how to extract insane amounts of cash,
have to have these
mansions in the Hamptons.
They figured it out.
Okay.
You can't be hating.
They can get a throw your system away.
It's infested with rats.
The system doesn't work at all,
but no one's willing to do that.
No one is willing to start from zero.
If you worked your whole life
and you get 50 grand in the bank,
you're not going to give that 50 grand up.
And neither is the guy who's
got $1 million in the bank.
He's not going to give
that million dollars.
Well,
and we're all going to start at zero.
I felt fuck Outta here.
I don't know.
I wouldn't cause there's a lot of assholes
out there that shouldn't even be a
zero.
They should be like a negative.
So fucking Lazy Bitches,
right?
There's a lot
of people that don't
contribute their share.
So unfortunately capitalism as,
as it stands right now as well,
we got no one was called
where a good alternative.
Well we need to,
it's really silly because in
2013 the idea that this is,
and I'm not a socialist by any
stretch of the imagination,
I,
I'm,
I'm more of a,
I think people need to pull their
own weight and a lot of people don't.
I think there's a lot
of lazy fucks out there.
There's a lot of people that just,
they lack motivation,
they lack direction,
they lack focus,
they self sabotage.
And he shouldn't reward that.
I don't think you should reward that.
But on the other hand,
this system is fucking crazy.
This stock market,
we,
you're gambling on the ups and downs
of Konya owning pieces of companies got
though,
but fuck no one even knows what it is.
The nuts
and stuff.
I've had friends that are stockbrokers
try to explain to me derivatives and I'm
like,
I wasn't that legal.
How is any of this legal,
how was shorting legal?
How is how our lobbyists legal?
It's like,
it's a fucking cookie system.
And you're like,
well someone should really
come in and overhaul it,
but they'll,
in order to do that,
he's homeless.
Like they,
they must know but it can't keep going on.
Seems like he's that on purpose.
Like it's an old car that
they keep trying to patch up.
That's what I think.
You know,
if you had like a 1950 fucking Chevrolet,
those are boring to drive.
They sucked those old fucking cars,
man.
If you got to get on the highway
every day and trends go from uh,
you know,
like a w say Sherman oaks to downtown La.
You had to make that drive every day and
the heat in a model t you would fucking
hate it.
You'd go crazy because
it's an old piece of shit.
No matter what you do,
whether you add a new stereo to it,
are you fucking put shiny rims on it.
It's designed like shit.
It's an old piece of shit.
You don't want to have to
drive an old piece of shit.
If I give you a,
a Nice Honda accord,
you'd be like,
ah,
look at this.
It's quiet and conditions doesn't fall
when I turned the wheel doesn't fall on
its side.
Those old cars,
we're pieces of shit
and that's our system.
Our system is old piece of shit
and we haven't thrown it out yet.
We haven't just like fucking grabbed it
and yanked the gears out and melted it
all down and made a new system.
If someone comes up with something,
which I'll never let them.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well that's it.
Well,
it's,
it's a,
it's a thinly disguised
king and,
and,
and disciple situation.
It's a thinly disguised the,
the,
the people that are in
the position of power.
It's not just one,
but it's a group that are unquestionably
the kings of this country.
But Pete,
but he's changing isn't it?
I think with the Internet where
people get more knowledge,
you know,
it's fellow food a lot more well off,
on,
oh what are
you doing dude?
I think with the people
that are in charge of it,
it's,
it's the only thing that's changing is
if it's out in the open and then people
are just accepting it
now with full knowledge.
Like when you see that
people can have like,
do you know anything about this?
I'm fast and furious.
Do you know what happened?
You hear about the gums
in Mexico?
Yeah,
well there's a thing called
the executive privilege.
You know,
like this is the president could say
he doesn't want to talk about it.
So they can just say,
second,
it looks like I'm not testifying.
Why?
Why not?
That's crazy.
Why not testify together?
What's the big deal?
And then wine look,
soul fucking shifty about it.
Did you see that?
Yeah.
I mean looked.
I mean,
you can't say,
yeah,
I'm fucking,
he fly in.
They,
if they didn't know that
something was gonna happen,
they absolutely did profit on
the fact that it did happen.
Yeah.
You know,
oh,
well you can't,
you can't die.
You can't do it.
It's the most obvious connected
John's paper trail ever.
If you look at like Dick Cheney
was the head of Halliburton.
Halliburton is accompany
that rebuilds countries,
Africa and that company,
the CEO is the vice president and all of
a sudden that companies making billions
of dollars,
like,
what are you talking about?
That's,
I wonder if maybe they knew
about it and maybe even how.
Tell me a little bit,
I don't know.
Then that way I'll maybe have a team
what do this and they don't really tell
them what they're doing in and what
it's for and you'd get the decide,
reflect without everyone knowing
what the fuck's going on.
I would like to tell you
that that's not possible.
That there's no one who'd
be willing to do that.
But the problem with saying
that is that the only,
the only real issue,
only real issue with someone would have
about our government doing that would be
that it's sacrificing American lives and
that they would kill American lives and
let American people die.
No,
they're here to protect us.
So that's the one thing that
some people would hold back.
But what they will undeniably would all
agree to is that we don't really have a
problem with killing
people and other countries.
We don't really have a problem
if we decide that they're,
the enemy will kill you with robots
that fly from the sky and shoot rockets
indiscriminately into villages.
Okay.
That's how it will kill you.
So the,
a company that's willing to do
that would just say a company,
let's call it a company
instead of a country.
Cause it's not really the whole con,
it's not us.
It's,
it's whoever the fuck is the one who
gets to pull the buttons and pull the
switches.
But that's why I think
they're willing to do that.
I don't forget,
can I,
that's why I don't think he can continue.
Like you said that he wove know
people are just known about it.
I'm doing nothing.
I think eventually the,
that just knowing about it,
I think the next stage is,
then we'll know that's why the
almond milk it can to keep going.
I think the problem is that
it's very hard to stop and the,
in fairness to the people
that are in military,
there's a lot
of them that joined the military with
very good intentions and they get into
that position and they're stuck
in a battle and it's not them.
That's the problem.
It's the,
the,
the problem is why would they
sent there in the first place?
Go once you're in,
once you're in for
everyone who's a soldier,
you know what it becomes,
man.
It becomes taking care of your friends.
That's what it comes.
It becomes taking care of your boys,
taking care of,
of your girls,
taking care of the people you love.
Those are the people you're
with every day in a war zone.
So it doesn't become about the,
your ideology,
whether or not you believe in this war,
it becomes not just a battle.
I mean,
and there's no way around that.
I was talking to my,
um,
my friend who's in the army,
I,
you know,
we were,
we would talk,
he's in the marines and
I was saying to him,
you know,
we just having a general discussion
about a fuck to is about this and that,
um,
you know,
basically doing the government's work.
Yeah.
I mean,
and he said to me,
um,
you know,
each all basically I off,
I always think I've got
got back cause I make,
so I make sure they're okay.
I love on,
I never fall of it like that.
He always has to go back and think
about his friend says to always,
yeah,
because they've been told that bomb gear,
you're fucking,
bullets are whizzing by you.
You're,
you're carrying each other.
Sometimes you know,
you're,
you're looking out for each other.
You're in a war zone.
That's what it becomes.
And so the,
the real issue is,
well,
how do you stop the whole thing?
How do you stop the whole thing?
Cause I don't know if you do because
you do a lot of God damn damage.
And then people that you did that damage
to are always going to want to come
back at you.
Yeah,
there's no doubt about it and there's
no doubt that this damage has been done.
So it's not an easy thing to step in
and sort of settle the world down.
But I do agree with you that the Internet
is changing it to the point where that
is the inevitable future.
I think the realization of what everyone's
actions are actually accomplishing it
and actually doing and
what to what detriment.
You know,
our actions or two,
it's going to get to a point where things
level out much more so than they ever
have in the past because governments
could do anything behind your back.
They could do,
do all kinds of sneaky shit and you can
never know about it ever until 50 60
years ago,
you know?
And then it's then people
started leaking information.
It's like the Kennedy Times.
That's when people say,
I mean before that.
I mean God damn.
How's the average person get information
that there's corruption going on in
society?
How does the average person get that?
You're not getting a lot of it,
but you're getting so much of it now.
It's like every day on Twitter and every
damn Facebook and everyday people are
emailing people links Twitter and shit
to their friends and it just gets to a
mad frenzy of ideas now too.
I don't even think we're
aware of how strange it is.
I think we're just used to it because
we're in it and this is our life now,
but I think if we looked at life today,
a few decades ago,
we would go,
this is crazy.
This is a fucking science
fiction movie with you.
Freaks came in,
came in early on a,
I was talking to Brian,
I'm,
and he showed me some
little fucking video,
like it's seven second line.
He was like the finger finger.
Look Dude,
I'm an shows.
Shows a little film.
I'm upside the next thing of than
Twitter or like a video message.
What?
Lost seven seconds.
So it's a video message for the last
seven times it was called vine and Brian's
got into it and the apparently a
lot of people like this silly shit.
Now look it up.
That's what I'm talking about.
And did you,
did you splice all this together yourself?
Does it automatically like it's literally
like you just push a button every time
you went to record and we don't push it.
It's just pauses the
recording and it just,
it makes the animated Gif on plot.
You just smash them all together yourself.
Yeah,
just does it automatically.
Oh that's cool.
And you're like,
oh I'm going to start using that shit.
It's fun man.
It's really addicting.
Everybody lasts but the cause crazy.
Everywhere you look people
are vining and so it just,
a bunch of people like walking
around like this in the air.
It's cause it vine.com no,
it's an APP on your iPhone.
Oh it's an athlete.
Yeah.
And it should be coming
out on [inaudible] soon.
Twitter just bought it cause
it link up with Twitter.
Yeah.
Oh power.
And you can also also send it
to Facebook and everything,
but it's really fun.
What can I keep my Twitter name?
Do I have to register a new name?
I think it's a,
yeah,
you can keep your Twitter name,
but it's also really weird because I
think you can just have a million names.
Oh,
that's great.
Yeah,
a lot of assholes.
It's really hard to find people as soon
as you allow people to be anonymous.
In the latter.
We have a bunch of different names.
I'm going to have
conversations with themselves.
We had a guy on our
message board wants that.
They busted doing that.
He had more than one account and
he was like talking to the cool,
like on message boards it would go
and like make some a post about his,
his music and then come back and say,
hey,
thanks man.
I really appreciate that.
Uh,
so about the art came aim.
It's classic.
It's hilarious.
What did you do today?
Oh,
you know,
talk to myself.
But it's kind of funny because it's,
is that any different than some bullshit
commercial their company puts out?
You know where you,
you know,
you drive down the street and like,
I'm so glad that we're here driving on
these Goodyear tires because they make me
feel secure,
tore shit to projected out you,
you're not going out and doing it.
I guess it's like,
it's more deceitful.
It's more boards will cringe fucking word.
Oh fuck.
Oh fuck you.
I have this whole,
don't y'all get
the fuck am I doing?
If you're just pissed off
that one time could you just,
and when I'm stupid
moods and that came out,
it done.
You can't do
that in a away.
Yeah.
You get to take your lumps.
That's a tough one because people are
just not going to trust you again.
You know they were talking,
we were talking yesterday with my
friend Sam Sherida about this author,
I forget the guy's name,
but he,
he made up a bunch of Bob Dylan quotes
and apparently it was like a great
author,
but he made up these quotes and then when
they like tried to check him on it and
tried to like find the
source of these quotes,
he like got arrogant about it.
And then they started researching
it and they wouldn't let it go.
And they apparently they found that he
just made them up to point and he's bald.
He could,
he could,
right?
Yeah.
Whatever you want it.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
You could put a Bob Dylan quote and say
some of the most poignant things at Bob
Evans was thinking this at
the time when Bob said this,
it spoke to my soul because I a child
who's been in the 60s I was on Haight
Ashbury.
I was,
I was wearing a Bandana
with live flowers in it.
The fucking freaks.
Yeah.
So this guy just ruined them,
ruined them.
So I think like this other guy,
it's kind of similar.
It's like no one's gonna really take you
seriously know he felt it lets you go
do io Oscar or something.
You're going to go to Peru.
You gotta prove yourself Fitch
man does coat two minute.
I've seen Mendez character,
the follow stele jokes.
Dealer character.
Farlow the drug dealer character diva
fucking jokes.
Taylor.
Oh,
Joe Sia.
Carla.
I don't know.
It's hard to understand.
You
don't quite know what
the fuck you been saying.
We do have a bit of an accent,
my friend.
Oh,
fucking hell.
Very.
It's funny,
like I remember a certain guys like Terry,
Adam,
Terry Adams got a very,
very strong accent.
Like he talks to you like,
Woo,
I don't want to put that together.
I don't know why Hitler England,
um,
Michael Bisping.
Yeah.
There's so many.
I don't know why England.
It's a small place,
right on the,
so many different accents,
line of access,
but a lot of it's a very strong accent.
You know,
it's interesting.
And uh,
it's the,
the accent,
it's,
it's very fitting for the
people that live in England.
Walk.
Do you mean because they
have to be tough because,
oh shit,
I've got a bit,
this is a
different place,
you know,
and the,
the fact that guys,
it's fucking different,
man.
It human beings.
We look at the whole world and we,
we like to think that it's just like,
it is here,
but it's over there.
We think like,
you know,
live in Africa,
live in Saudi Arabia,
whatever,
man.
As long as we're there together,
it'll be like,
you know,
it'd be like us.
He,
no,
that's,
that's not the case.
You go to England,
you know,
well this is a different world.
These guys have completely
different expectations.
They drive it on the lefthand
side.
They don't give a fuck about you more.
You're crazy.
Laws are,
your quarters don't mean shit there.
They're not real.
You know,
it's like,
wow,
this is a totally different
place with their own money.
And like,
you know,
you'll see people on TV that
are important and you're like,
who the fuck is that guy?
You have no idea who
their prime minister is.
I have no idea who any
of these people are.
You know,
you hear like Margaret Margaret
Thatcher every now and then we know her,
we know the prints.
We know that like,
well,
we'll follow your royal family,
but I don't know what
the fuck is going on.
You know?
So it's,
it's fascinating to be over.
It's a totally different world.
You know,
England is,
it's first of all,
it's kind of a massive amount of history.
There's so much history in England.
There's so many years.
Many,
many.
Like if you look at the
history of the United States,
you're only dealing with
like 200 plus years,
but England,
you're like,
Jesus Christ,
you guys go back over a thousand so it's
like you have some really old pubs that
have been open since like
the 14 hundreds right?
Aren't there
some real real fucking oh shit.
And England we called Shit.
Oh Shit.
Go to a pub.
Stop and think about that.
That's been open since the 14 hundreds
I'm spelled the same.
Fuck man,
ain't biomed.
How did you guys deal with,
you know,
you have kings and Queens
still while you lease,
you have acquainted but you don't really,
they don't really get
to tell you what to do.
Well,
it's a different situation.
It's like,
it's almost like they're like
actors playing the queen.
Yeah,
slightly.
The
other deal,
I'm the captain a lot,
you know,
you just,
they'd give him money and they make
them look bad ass and they wave.
They do like that and they just
show the most proper behavior.
And then if they don't,
you know what I mean?
That's why the public,
the queen gets all pissed off because
we could lose half fucking money.
Yeah,
you can lose that Gig context.
Fucking fight.
You got to act royal
portion popper posh and proper and calm.
Yeah,
and creep on.
If you see that,
like that whole set up with
the castle and all that jazz,
it's really fascinating because
they don't really run the country,
right?
No.
Do No home.
You guys have like a democracy,
right?
Yeah,
100% yeah.
Yeah.
Do,
do,
do kings can go.
Pop was not pry them.
Can you try them for
crimes and shit like that?
No.
I think that I,
this is what
you calm but I can,
I can,
if it was something,
if the king got kink it the queen got
call during something like Lesbos Shit.
Oh,
you can't even say that.
Hey can I just did American bitch land
of the free home of the brave and I'm
going to fuck.
Oh,
I can't tell you.
I can't tell you that.
I won't tell you that for my queen.
No.
Cross the line.
Not True.
I never sent jokingly as a
gentleman's is all jokes,
no disrespect man to Her
Majesty the Queen as a joke.
But if she did,
what have we got?
A bad ass bitch.
What'd she had like some hot 20 year
old like Puerto Rican chick with like
red lipstick and big areolas and shit.
Her and the queen just
got caught making out.
Could you talk about why?
What's wrong with that man?
Wouldn't it be great?
Great if it was a guy,
right?
Wouldn't it be great if it was a guy
who was a guy who was an old guy?
The queen single.
Okay.
If the old guy by himself
all of a sudden boom,
he's got this hot 20 year old,
just unbelievably ridiculously sexually
attractive woman on his lap making out
with them.
Wouldn't that be awesome?
It would,
right?
Well,
is there anything wrong?
Bls,
vion.
I say there's not.
I see there's nothing
wrong with being a lesbian.
So I say if the queen was a lesbian
and she was getting some hot posts,
good for her.
I don't want to see it.
I don't want to see it happen.
But off to say you don't want to see,
you don't want to send you a link.
You're going to college.
You're going to click that link.
I'm going to send you a link to Colossae.
Motherfucker too.
Man picks thing.
I know I'm going to about
500 times in a row while gambling.
Oh yeah,
that's,
yeah,
but you wouldn't want to watch.
You would still want
to watch you to queen.
Have a good time.
There's nothing wrong with,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't know.
You wouldn't.
Just out of out of fair.
What is that?
It's the Prince Harry or whatever it.
They got a picture of
him naked and the chick
in Vegas who did that?
Who took that picture?
I think the folks had a circus circus.
The circus art cause they went,
they went hunting rest
house and style in Vegas,
acid it up and circus circus.
That real picture.
Was that a hidden camera or something?
I think they probably
tell your people that.
It's not a real picture,
but I bet you know what I bet it is,
man.
I bet a lot of people that
are inside the organization,
they do that shit on purpose.
They leaked that stuff for publicity.
They build a business.
You don't think that's a rough patch.
I know I fucked a kid.
You guys holding his Dick?
I don't hold my Dick when I'm by myself.
Okay.
If I'm walking around the Vegas,
I'm slinging a dick.
Like when did that start?
When did that come on?
It's slapping my left side's
slap on my right side.
I'm not holding it like that.
That guy's holding it because he
knows they're taking a picture.
That's what I say.
Okay.
That was some Colombo type shit,
son.
I want some credit for that.
It was leaked to Geiber
and Tom Selleck combined.
If it's a picture of you
name Vegas Holding your deck.
Oh,
look at it.
come on man.
These are,
these guys know these
pictures are being taken.
Nope.
No,
that Israel.
I think someone busted out a cell phone.
That's what I think you're saying.
No real because you believe that it's
impossible for royals to do anything
wrong.
How many people are still
brainwashed by the royals?
In in England.
Is it like still an important thing left
field if you will like fuck the queen
when people are like,
oh it depends on your circle of friends.
Well as my friends,
your friends wouldn't know.
They'd be like,
yeah for the Queen.
But because if you,
if you said you're allowed to
say like fuck the president,
you could say that in this
country and people will go,
hey,
easy.
But they won't like attack
you and beat you up.
But I would imagine by the way,
all that stuff that I
said about the queen,
these are just choke.
So He's a gentleman.
I just,
no disrespect meant we're
talking about the queen.
I would go with it about my own mother.
Okay.
I would say that joke about my
own mother because it's not like,
again,
nothing wrong with being a lesbian.
And if my mom was lesbian I
wanted to hook up with a hottie.
So it's my own mom who I love more than
anybody on the planet cause my mom.
So no worries about it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
these are just jokes.
Um,
how many people were like,
cause like I know that it's,
it's,
it's got a lot more reverence
to it then the president does,
right?
Yeah.
Well like,
like I said earlier,
it's so old,
so old it even go back.
Like I don't even know cause I think
how the fuck did that come to pass?
Jemaine like that.
Basically.
So hardest.
He's got the fucking hobbyist gang.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's what it was.
Yeah.
At one point in time and the good good
kings are the ones who didn't abuse you
too much.
Oh,
he's a good kid.
Yeah.
He sent me mileage.
It's this living way better than you and
for no reason [inaudible] behind him.
People.
Oh you be heading a wives.
Like what was that one guy,
Henry,
the Henry the eighth.
That's when the kid get chopped.
A bunch of his wives heads off.
They got a little mouthy.
He's was like,
bitch,
I'm done.
I'm done with this.
Yeah,
he got,
he would get sick of
them and assassinate him.
I wonder what he would charge them with.
Like,
I don't need much of an excuse,
but I bet he had a thing.
Some probably a ledger people's
heads he chopped off probably.
Yeah,
you will.
You watch like shows like game of Thrones
and I know it's bullshit where ladies
and gentlemen before I'll talk about
game of Thrones and people were like,
you know,
so real right.
I'm like,
please give me more credit than this.
I saw the dragons are southern,
which is,
I'm sure it's not real,
but it's supposed to
represent at least the idea,
the idea of a time,
you know,
it's supposed to represent without all
the fantasy stuff attached to it as well.
But it's also supposed to represent an
idea of a time when there was blacksmiths
and swords and horses,
but that was the technology.
It sort of ended there.
There wasn't really any medicine.
There wasn't really any refrigerators.
He just had fucking plates of fruit.
If you were the king,
like drumsticks,
massive ones,
Turkey legs and shit.
What with the big fucking baby
mutton in a beer Stein Stein,
right?
Like ever see.
Yeah,
I love that.
That's your people.
It's a good movie.
That's a fun movie.
Which was that a cartoon?
Yeah.
Amazing.
Cgi.
That was a great fun movie.
Selena jellies.
Boobies.
Cartoon.
Angelina Jolie.
You remember when that goes?
Some bid as Shitty as Lindsay
Lohan got some big ass.
That's a good song.
Great Song.
Halle Berry got some big ass titties.
She just,
if you could find that,
but it'll get us kicked off youtube.
Well,
I don't think it was like a real song.
There's not registered.
Give it a chance because
there's no way they fucking car.
I'm helping them.
Jesus Christ.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we have to worry about getting
our shit booted off youtube.
If we have copyrighted material
sometimes got some big ass titties.
Halle Berry got some big ass titties.
Yeah.
That could have been a fun way.
Even if you were the king.
I would rather be a dude who has like
a decent job today than a king in 2000
years ago.
Wouldn't you
know Kakadu good.
You could do good if you were the king.
Oh,
is that how you would rock it?
They'll kill you.
They'll go right after
you fucking kill you.
Usually is this
big ass titties time,
Lindsay loans.
If he see
cups of tea cups,
sweater,
I'm trying to,
it's,
I'm so happy that black
people exist because white
people will never figured out
what app they would have never figured
out how you could brag like endlessly and
it actually can be an art
form and for fun to listen to.
It's fun to listen to.
White people lack the flavor to
have come up with rap on their own.
Like we needed black people
around to like spice it up,
which very important.
There's,
it would never come out with that.
There's a song out right now,
Joe,
it's from bear.
I got some big ass today.
The guy's named like asap
rocky I think as this name.
And it's caught fucking
problems and there so many,
so many cuss words in the song that
that when they played on the radio,
it's seriously,
they drink it.
Like you're sitting there like,
wait a sec,
I,
you can't understand a word they're
saying but has this catchy like,
like Ryan that's underneath it that
you get into and now it's like a number
three song.
And you can't understand a word
that's the name of it.
It's called fucking problems by asap.
Rocky.
Actually [inaudible] version,
but I don't want to play,
I don't even play it.
I think that the universe is letting
us know in no uncertain terms that it's
over the fucking shows over.
It's getting completely wacky.
I think that's what reality TV is.
I think that's what this song will be.
The number three songs in the
world go back to like the year,
whatever it was,
when midnight rider came out
from the Allman brothers.
And to compare that song to this fucking
ridiculous song that has a million
customers that you can't even play.
It's just a core.
It's free.
It's so ridiculous.
Want to hear it?
It's,
it's the aliens are sending
us a signal to saying,
build your ship.
Okay,
and get off this rock.
They're going to start eating each other.
It's fucking honey booboo.
It's going to become an adult and
she's going to run the planet.
That's what's going to happen,
dude.
What is the next,
yeah,
what is accident?
What was the wall?
Um,
what's next for you,
man?
Do you just fought right.
Where'd you fight?
Not,
not for while I let,
my last flight was Bobby
Lashley and I got my cheat bump,
Balkan.
Um,
my Alberto bone got fuck shoots up.
Popped me out for a while.
That was a big victory for you.
Yeah,
it was a legit victory.
Like a good big name.
Yeah,
it was a good fight.
You know,
you,
you pulled it off for three rounds.
Yeah,
I watched it not long ago on a fault.
Just edged it,
Josh.
Sacha.
It was close.
Um,
those are satisfying,
aren't they?
Well,
I mean,
I went to plan,
I stopped his take downs.
My cardio was a much better if you
did take me and I got right back up.
I felt good.
But why let me down with standup?
My standard was too slow.
It was like he was beating me to it.
I was main event,
finish him off with his standup,
but he was too quick.
Um,
it was beating me to
the punch and I thought,
right,
fuck it.
I'm going to have to get them to
the cage and make it just massive.
Just keep him in because he was tired.
He want to move to keep him.
Fuck him.
Well,
it was good where I managed
to do what I want to do,
but I didn't capitalize.
That guy is a weird example
of like a physical specimen.
He's so muscular.
You're looking at me go,
how could that guy,
he did more cardio.
He seems like a guy who probably
should be like a two or five or right.
Yeah.
It's too big for his family.
He's got so much meat on him,
but he's so impressive looking.
Yeah.
Because of that,
it used to be at a time,
you know,
you look at a guy who's
built like that and go,
well that guy,
I'd probably kick a lot of apps,
but now you know,
like that guy is handicapped
almost like when you to bag.
It's like when I fought
[inaudible] and so many gaps.
Yeah.
You
know what?
I remember he was
statistically based strong,
so he got me in a belly
to belly suplex me over,
um,
you know,
uh,
landed on it.
He was on top of me and I felt like
under hook and eye he was just a big gap.
Closes.
I am too.
So also is
not aware.
I mean he's,
he's mixed martial arts training.
It's very limited.
I watched him hit the pads and everything.
It's like it was comical.
So like well this guy never punched in
his life and they teach them how to punch
now that soaks these mindset.
Yes.
And animal.
Well a fucking animal.
The fuck t fault.
Do you know what I was
talking earlier about,
you know,
six weeks and I ain't got big ego book.
I've got Marvin,
he got that obviously.
How he visualized due to John,
I mean right because put your Nice Keith,
thanks for you know he
jumps in the Tim Silvia.
Yeah.
Tell me fucking it's a worst fight
ever.
Ever.
He's so tall.
So vain G,
very dangerous guy.
And if I ever motivated,
cause he just lost to Ray
Mercer said wanted it,
you know,
he,
that was an embarrassing,
lost it.
Yeah.
So he wanted to,
to,
to put a good mark on his ledger and put,
you announced it was a perfect one,
eight pudgy now scalable high,
like you fucking know.
It was like the body beautiful versus
a guy with not the greatest shit.
Yeah,
no,
not the greatest.
Genetics kicked the fucking
shit out of that body.
Beautiful.
Easy.
It wasn't no problem.
It was a,
it fascinating to see how willing that
guy is like right away to fight high
level guys.
It's going back.
It's going pop quiz.
He started off
like that and then after
the second loss to me,
which is bullet,
it wasn't lost to me.
He was,
he claimed to have won the fight
and then they've invested decision.
Well
that,
that's some fuckery right there.
Is that in Poland and how
do you know what it is it,
do you know why I was up?
He to me always fucking up his to
me because I'm the guy who's mad,
he'd been knocked Tate.
I'm like,
the goats had a few.
I'm semi legitimate.
So I'm like,
but people like,
oh,
you know,
he's got,
um,
you know,
he's had a few wins.
He's,
he's not a complete bomb.
So they put me up there,
I look the part,
I'll come to fight but unbeatable.
So then you know that guy who's
ready to take the next level,
he's thinking he's beating Tim Silvia,
don't forget [inaudible] I think
the fucking Fuck Thompson up.
But it didn't quite go,
go,
go like that.
Yeah.
I think also that's the thing,
the guy became this amazing
power lifting champion,
this strong man champion because he has
just an undeniable belief in himself.
So he probably just thinks
he doesn't give a fuck.
He keeps running into reality.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
That kind of needs like a it guy like
that needs like a real legit coach.
Like a Greg Jackson or a Matt Hume.
Like someone's going to
sit them down and go,
listen,
there's only one way we're going
to do this and do it right.
You going to keep your brain okay and
that she actually learned how to fight and
then you fight.
I think he is.
Yeah,
Tom.
And be getting smaller.
It's getting smaller as well.
Right.
He's getting back what
Catholic and you know,
took me the fuck it's mine.
You know what I mean?
So I forget
that part I give him credit for,
but he's a fucking prick.
He's a pro Israel.
It's eyes.
He's not a nice guy.
Do you know when I was at KSW?
Um,
of the staff or the no,
I had to,
I talked to when he was really nice on uh,
on the,
on the doing song grabs you hand when
someone grabs your hand to shake it and
then they do that finger thing.
No,
no,
no.
I'm the golf.
Oh yeah,
with the second arm.
Why did they do that?
You like get your base,
you lower your base.
This mother is good at judo.
Me fucking out.
Joe Bitch.
Yeah.
Why?
Why did they do,
but I think it says an emphasis to
really have to really have a home.
It's a hand hug.
I don't mind it as long as it's a touch
to touch with the other arm when you
grabbed my wrist.
Especially if you go with one of the gene,
the bell finger lock type of situation.
I don't think that thinking of it like
three fingers and you really got to
fucking read the gene about fucking
handbook and he shoots this great time.
Great Handbook.
If you want to fucking
kill somewhere walking,
weird dudes will do.
Well they'll hold onto your knee
whether telling you something.
What the fuck is that
when you're sitting down,
are you sitting down like in some
easy chairs next to each other?
Older dudes would do it.
When they have a,
they got some important to tell.
You know,
Bobby,
I need to suck your Dick Right now.
I'm thinking,
boy,
the Dahlia I like and they
want you to really listen.
They will like hold your,
they were like even put a hand
like not even like a full claw,
but to let you know that if he wanted to
they could make the shit uncomfortable.
I tell you some shit about the government.
They don't have this happen to me.
You don't talk to old dudes.
Yeah.
I talked to the old dudes that want
us to show me that they know shit.
The worst one for me to,
I've got this black eye.
Um,
the,
the worst one for me is people grabbing,
you had to,
you know,
when the past and they come
up on the crop that Bucky,
I'd like and then start pulling you in.
Yeah.
They want to talk to you almost.
I'm like,
well,
they're just fucking pulling you,
you know,
not letting you get a fucking
way taking the choice away.
I mean,
yeah,
yeah.
Why do people do that when
they want to talk to you?
Hold on to you.
So we pause because it's so
important what they're going to say.
Dan Henderson the back
of your head and shit.
No Man.
When,
when tone does that to me,
you know,
we'd be training as well.
What's going to start
to me it's like fuck.
So that's how he got that black eye.
Yeah.
What happened while I was,
um,
I work,
well he's my main,
but I go to his club and I do security
for just normal clothes off a drink with
him.
I got,
I don't,
I do whatever.
I fucking want a drink.
Um,
so I was going on with security,
but you're also like a patriot.
Okay.
So you just do it to hang out with them?
Yeah,
I told you we don't even have to pay me.
Oh,
okay.
I told her you know about,
but he does anyone who's your voice.
So you go there and you hang out with,
so your security just by existing.
There you go.
So,
uh,
so,
so then what,
like what am I saying?
I don't know.
I don't go to it.
Yeah,
that's why I hope it's
gonna be good though.
So,
so if I can remember that.
So W W we,
we there and um,
so if someone punches the binary black,
oh yeah,
yes.
So on punches the bathroom and floods,
it punched the bathroom.
He pumps the fucking container
with the Walkman or something.
And,
and,
and how you guys have like one of
them old school above the toilet?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
So I,
so I went to look for the guy who did it,
so I said,
oh,
I'll have a look.
And he said,
white tee shirt.
So I'm on the way down the dance floor.
And um,
this girl steps from a toll,
she steps on your toe
and she wobbles a bit.
So I capture under the arm securely safe.
And I got and she goes,
oh yeah.
She said something to me.
And then this bloke came out of
nowhere fucking peacock in it.
I get invited my face,
peacock minute means
spreading as feathers.
Yeah.
He's letting me talking shit.
I was like talking to his message.
He just happened to like this skinny
fucking much look to light from the back
foot turned her face was hollow.
She had fucking Lord to make
the story better.
Is that math out couple?
She,
yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Needle needles and then fucking
needles fall out of refineries.
Oh,
stop it.
Um,
and the guy dropped it.
He started saying,
I said something to him and he
was taking my kind of kindness,
uh,
me being okay.
I don't want to find no reason to,
so might be an ally and he's
taking that as a weakness.
I can see it happening and I,
it's almost like a know what's
going to happen if I can't do it.
I could just say fuck off
quick and just kill it dead,
but I don't,
and it anywhere law.
And uh,
then he did that and I pushed his hand
off and he fucking hit me fucking that
left hook,
man.
You hit him back.
Did you bring his arm?
You cannot fucking colossus leak.
Yeah.
That's a big mistake when you punch it,
dude like you,
and then he's still there
and now you're mad like,
dammit.
Are you ticklish?
No,
you are [inaudible] his head.
Move
on.
Do it Brian.
He'll,
he'll break this whole fucking table.
Brian.
Sit the fuck down.
You better not take on
any motherfucker my deck.
I will kill him to see that he's Riley
and he getting confident and again,
comfortable with gay.
He's trying to lure you into his
fucking spider web spider web of issues.
Yeah.
Give me one of them two below.
That stuff's great.
Um,
thanks to a CTO,
coconut water for sending
us all this delicious.
If you ever,
uh,
have a chance,
like if you're looking for
like coconut water to buy it,
they are not created equal.
You want to make sure you get coconut
water that's from these Thai coconuts.
That's [inaudible].
That's uh,
Brian and fucking Amy,
Amy and Brian's.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Amy and Brian's is,
uh,
the same,
same time.
Hey,
he's the tickling each other.
This is dangerous.
He wouldn't even mean to kill
you by would just be an accident.
I love him on the hook.
You know,
gone.
Always killed a number one bus.
Oh,
poor Brian.
I would never kill you opponent.
He would hug you and everything
would just leak out of your asshole.
I would a water bag,
watch
love and affection.
His ass would just open up this rep,
the whole inner,
it's just plot everything.
Rib Cage,
everything for,
no one's even going to figure out how
rib cage got through his ass go right
through intact toying.
It's going to come out
and roll across the floor
where he realized he wasn't really,
what can you Brian,
it's something that I've already started
because I'm extremely ticketless and,
and if I was a fighter,
I think if I was like in
some crazy Jiu Jitsu thing,
if the guy just started tickling me,
freak the fuck out.
No,
no,
not when you're in the moment.
I'm thinking of because why
your chicken on the guy,
the guys on top are you punching you
in the face and you're going to stop
tickling part of Ticklin like the whole
thing is like someone's like got power
over you and you're like stop it.
You're making me feel
things I don't want to feel,
you know,
but it doesn't hurt but
it just feels weird.
Not at all.
Cause you know what,
you're,
you make the connection between
the impact of the fingers,
but when someone else is controlling
that you don't know what kind of ride
you're going on and all that shit
is actually probably evolutionary,
um,
to uh,
beneficial to keep spiders off of us.
Like things that like
little things are moving.
Like what am I going back?
That's what that is.
It's like extra sensory for when spiders
and shit would crawl into your fucking
sleeping bag,
you know?
I mean that's probably what ti
being ticklish is all about.
You,
you have a sleeping back
fucking fucking the day.
Yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
I know Bryan always has a,
a rescue pack in his car.
Well,
he's ready for this new Jack strangles
me to sleep or worried about the
earthquake.
And so he a a full emergency
set up in the back of his car,
including ecstasy.
Plenty of Molly fucking palm star.
No,
there's none in the trunk or
I cleaned it out last night.
That's why those ones,
you say it and you're like,
damn,
it was,
it seemed like it was there.
I took a chance,
I threw it out there.
We bonk.
So,
um,
you got,
two big wins in a row,
right?
With Bob South and with no,
it was Bob's happened
in the same cell phone.
Oh,
that's right.
The same I've Bobby Lashley
if I have three big wins on the fourth,
which is our class size or when,
because it was a Bullock's
poaching Osceola.
Yeah,
that was totally horse shit.
So,
um,
but the um,
the Superfight league is in India.
You enjoying that over there?
I'm not with them anymore.
You're not with them anymore.
What happened?
They cut my,
well,
they said to me,
we can get you a fight.
Um,
it was um,
we've got you,
we want you to find what's his face,
Todd Duffy.
And it's like,
okay.
And then like we want
to cut half your money.
Well,
and then where we want to
charge you 20% tax Indian tech.
So they changed how they do business with
you and they didn't charge Indian tax
before that 10%.
Are they outsourcing?
Is that what's called the
outsourcing heavyweights?
India's outsourcing as well.
We outsourced to India.
They had sorts heavyweights.
They,
they,
they just,
I think it did.
I think a guy has a lot
of money and the CMA,
I think I'd like to do that.
Right.
And you don't have it.
I like it.
And then the call to do it and uh,
he's not quite as simple as that.
They start bleeding money.
Well,
but people don't know what the fuck it is.
Like me and Bob sat there and it's like,
you know,
it's wrestling,
right.
Really?
Cause we both La and were,
they both walked through this crazy thing
at the fucking press Konza or I to get
you.
And he's like,
ah.
And then the guys in the middle
where the Bollywood guys,
you know what I mean?
Right.
So it looks like bullshit.
And then when Bob Sapp got injured,
it really looked like bullshit.
Right?
Yeah.
I tried to fall out,
boy.
Yeah.
But the first fight,
it's been like the first ever UFC,
it's fucking tooth comes out.
That song gets fucking smacked.
Oh,
it's really,
it was like that,
right?
This guy comes out Kinda,
uh,
professor acts.
Yeah.
Al bought someone me
and I'm straight away.
It's fun.
They had some good fights,
but is it that the guys
running out of cash,
it's costing a lot of [inaudible] capture.
Think he don't like losing it.
Oh,
so he's losing that.
So he's trying to like
minimize your mouth.
He's losing basically.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's not easy to fucking put
together a gigantic organization.
Know a lot of people don't realize that
the UFC was $44 million in the hole
before it started to turn around and
kind of profitable and that all became a,
because of the ultimate fighter,
they,
they bank rolled that show.
They essentially put together a show,
produced it,
and then bought time on spike to air it.
You know,
it's really crazy,
crazy fucking gamble.
But the one that turned out incredibly
well to get that level of recognition for
your organization,
you got to have something
like via common behind you.
You're like what Bellah tours doing.
You've got to have
something big behind you.
You have to have a push where they have,
okay,
look,
we have determined that we
have x amount of talent.
We have this amount of budget,
we can go after new talent.
We can offer people a commensurate,
you know,
a cash reward for wins that
you would get in the UFC.
We can their money.
So let's,
let's get crazy here.
Let's see what we can do.
But you have to be willing to lose a
lot of fucking to do that because until
they start doing paper views,
man,
until they started doing paper views,
where's all that money coming from?
You can have some swirled
championship fights.
Indians on the most athletic of people
either didn't know what they were great
wrestlers at one point in time as a spot.
The Indian physique as a whole,
not so good.
What about the women though?
No,
often not.
But the Bollywood,
once you've gotten the kind of thing
where they all want to be English,
right?
I mean,
so get as white as we can be and do
like the Japanese or the Chinese.
I've seen it a few hot Indian porn stars.
Yeah,
I mean,
absolutely.
I mean these hot everyone.
That's true.
You know what I mean?
Right.
But on,
on the average,
not so much,
which,
no,
I'm into self fucking Paul.
Either women are thinking
about fucking eating mean.
Nevermind.
It's flat for,
Huh.
When I went,
um,
first time doing a press conference,
I could not fucking believe it.
I mean you see it on the,
but that there was chaos.
It,
do you know what you were saying earlier?
Like over here there's
that different countries,
different worlds.
Fucking India.
I mean I've been to a few places,
but that I was worried for my
message and Mylene I grants and uh,
she,
she said suicide.
I'm surprised we haven't got this kid,
like a little kid in the middle
of the world eating a banana,
just sat there and it was busy as fuck.
And the,
the um,
oh shit.
The thing,
what fucking separates the world was
about that much and this little kid was
eating and Brianna just chilled out and
the song and the car going past wow.
And I was like
a strip of road on the street in
the middle and no one gives a fuck.
No one gives a fuck.
And I was like,
and then grant says to us,
fucking,
I'm surprised you not seen any
wild dogs or anything like that.
I'm literally turned my head and
there's this massive big fucking bull.
Yeah.
Just fuck.
I forget.
It was a bull walking down
the road and I was like,
fuck.
They said mad,
just chaos.
And I walked on the road,
I won't know.
So no one walks on the pavement.
Everyone walks on the fucking road and
a ball was just walking down the street.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ just,
okay.
I watch out for the kid.
A fucking ball and a
kid on the same street.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think he just madness everywhere.
Just madness.
Everyone in your life.
And then when we went to our hotel,
the apocalypse,
I mean if you,
if,
if you can,
you know,
if that came to England,
it would be the apocalypse,
right canal.
They all came to London.
Yeah.
There'll be the apocalypse that,
that big fucking game over.
But it is the apocalypse,
right?
It's just there.
Yeah.
So she can go visit the apocalypse,
but they will all,
they will for him.
On the beach going in the going into the,
uh,
with the whole cloves on.
Wow.
I've,
which I know that's sort the little thing,
but it just seemed soul nor some
baby knows lying on the beach.
Everyone was just standing on the beach
and in the water with the whole clause
on it.
And I have hope and that fight is
that they're washing the clothes.
I,
I don't,
I fucking don't know while they fired.
Fuck.
But your problem to some
parts can be is huge.
But Cindy bands have a real tiger
problem over the last 200 years.
I think 300,000 people have been killed
there signing some insane number like
that.
Like they have a real problem.
They have brackish water where it means
the water is not fresh and it's not
salt.
It's a combination.
It's not quite the solidity
of salt of seawater,
but it's,
it's more salty than regular freshwater.
And because of that,
the Tigers have nothing else to drink.
And they drink that shit and they get
really agitated or they get really
aggressive,
don't die well,
they die,
they become monsters.
And he said,
well,
it doesn't work that way.
You can imagine all you do
is add salt to tie forever.
That'd be fuck no,
they um,
they get,
they,
it's just only in theory that
that's why they're so aggressive.
But the,
also the other theories that
the typhoons come and I guess a,
these crazy storms that come,
a lot of people die.
You know,
a lot of people that are like near
the water or wind up in the water.
So the Tigers wind up eating the bodies
that washed down the shore and there's
so many of them in the water.
Apparently they will just,
a bunch of tigers will jump in
and they have no other meat.
They'll just eat these bodies.
They don't mind doing that.
So then they develop a
taste for human flesh.
So if the monsoons come or typhoons
or whatever they are and you know,
kill a bunch of villagers in,
a few of them wind up in the
water and tigers eat him.
Those tigers now know what people
tastes like and they go looking for it.
That's where it should get spooky.
We'll watch.
Talk me about India.
Like when we went,
when I went to hospital,
I was still half an extra week because,
uh,
obviously I was having my face.
Um,
so what happened when the guy,
this is from when the
guy sucker punched him?
No,
no,
no.
This is from Bobby.
Last rites.
Bobby last night he put my,
up until he broke it,
he brought me out.
The what happens when you
have an orbital break?
Do you have to mash apartment?
You've got some,
apparently these are collapsible and they
obviously designed to be that the I'd
flops down.
He protects your eyes.
So it broke on the Po God
in that like a titanium God
and now it's fucking good as gene.
So they put a titanium guardian your face.
Do you think you have dudes will ever
get titanium guards putting their face
without it breaking?
Just to push tactic?
Just show you don't get broken.
Orbitals yeah,
I mean it would work,
right?
Well,
I don't know because it's
meant to be collapsible.
So much not,
I said to the doctor,
oh,
I said to him,
he
just wanted to be collapsible.
And he says,
yeah,
I stuck with the titanium plate.
Won't be cops,
will.
He said,
no,
it won't.
If that's all,
if it won't collapse,
does that mean my eyes in more danger on?
And he said,
wow,
I would have fired if I was you.
I know folks like that.
Well he wouldn't fight
if he was you anyway.
That's how I fall off.
Well,
what fucking stupid thing to say.
If you were,
if it was you,
you would not know.
So I said to him,
is it safe?
And he said,
if I would do,
I would have,
I wouldn't fight.
And I fought.
That's what an answer.
But that's it.
First of all,
he's being honest,
cause he's not a fighter.
He's a doctor.
Yeah.
But I don't need his opinion
on fucking everything.
Meniscus surgery.
And The lady was telling me
never to do Jujitsu again.
You need to stop just
some meniscus surgery.
What are you talking about?
Oh,
you need to stop.
You're going to be crippled
by the time you get old,
your knees won't work.
You're like,
Whoa,
I have so many arguments.
We doctors about storage and things
like that because they don't know.
You tried to get prescriptions and
that's like a little mark right here
in my back.
I
go to Mexico,
man.
Super easy.
No,
no,
the Boba tea.
So many arguments because the event,
like I said,
they don't actually,
they see a lot of the negative effects
and they don't actually know what they're
talking about.
Well,
there's,
there's an issue with a lot of doctors
when it comes to two areas and one of a
big one is nutrition is a real issue
with a lot of doctors that are really not
that much more informed than the lay
person when it comes to nutrition.
If you're the average person that reads
an article or two here and there about
the benefits of vitamin C or you know,
Alpha lipoic acid or whatever
the fuck you read about,
you probably know as much as your
average general practitioner.
They don't really know that
much about nutrition on average.
I mean there's the course,
there's exceptions to the rule and
when you're dealing with something,
uh,
like nutrition,
which is,
you know,
an integral part of your
health in the first place.
It's a weird thing when the
doctors are only like their,
their idea of wellness,
there's only taking care of
you but actually are broken.
It's not like completely stopping all
this shit from happening in the first
place and like stepping in
and giving you nutrition and
picks up.
But then again,
they have to understand that the
body is a finite proposition.
And if a man wants to be a fighter,
then you've got to patch them back up
and send them out there and it says
decisions.
I wouldn't fight it if I was you,
but he's an and you,
yeah.
You wouldn't be a doctor
if you are him when Alpha.
I was like,
Oh
yeah,
there's,
um,
is there,
uh,
a point where you think,
like,
if you look at like your career,
like if you look at your future,
if you,
we,
you say,
well,
okay,
well if I get to this point,
no,
you just can do it and to enjoy it
while I stopped enjoying it for years.
I fucking hate it for four years,
four,
five years when I start gambling.
Um,
and then I've met,
I hate it.
I'd have like little spells
where I would be like,
oh,
I can't do it anymore.
I don't want to the pressure,
the fucking head fuck of it all the best.
And then when I get my money
and money gambling it all,
I've just,
uh,
you know,
I mean,
I can't do it anymore and I can't keep
bringing myself back up like Kimball,
who was meant to be a big comeback,
uh,
the put genetically,
you know,
keep it going.
Does that,
you know,
bought a bean that bollock just a lot
of bad decisions and so by me as well,
but not just so,
not just bad decisions,
just bad results.
Well,
but results are some
caused by me and some,
some just bad decisions.
I mean,
it's not just the Kimball
was seen by how many people,
they must say there was a huge audience.
Right.
8 million people,
I think six or eight.
I can't remember.
I most people,
what they remember is that you came into
the cage with a fucking mouse living in
your hair.
You had a like a whole
mouse family and it blew up,
right?
Yeah.
It popped in the middle of the fight.
It was so hard to watch.
That was the most fucked up
ear ever seen on national TV.
No one had a more fucked up.
Your Mri.
My is from a famous,
I'm man,
I'm jealous.
I'm jealous on my,
Eh.
We'll talk about that fight when we
were that guy that fuck Kimbo what?
The crazy fucking ear.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
Colossus.
I'm not going to be remembered.
Fall out though for that.
No.
Wow.
You'll,
you'll be remembered for
your entire career of sure.
No,
what I'm saying,
don't know what I'm saying is the moment,
the moment.
And people would say,
I'm the Kimball.
You know what I remember,
I remember you had Kimbo in side
control and they stood you up.
Yeah.
You know,
I remember that,
right.
Nobody had the point side.
I always say this,
I,
I take a lot of mold not
changing the fucking paper.
You don't stand as a guy up when the guy,
yeah.
Yeah.
[inaudible] was a corrupt organization.
Corrupt one of them.
They changed the rules.
They told guys to stand up and bang.
They told guys stand up and bang.
They gave them instructions and they made,
they made the referee
stand guys up much earlier.
Big country was fighting Andrea
[inaudible] and had him in a fucking side
control position working a
Komora and they stood in backup.
I'm like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Jake shields is,
they did that same shit
when he was fighting Paul.
Um,
uh,
Semtex when he's fighting Paul Daley,
same shit.
They tried to stand them up.
Rarely,
but Jake just attack,
attack,
attack and got him in an arm bar.
He just went Jake's high level black
belt.
So he just went after it really quickly.
But you had Kimbo in fucking side control.
You work to get it.
You got it.
You are a dominant position.
He was tired and they
stood you back up bitches.
We did a um,
a video interview,
you know,
everyone's on the other line and I've
just finished training so I'm on the
phone,
I want to,
no one was asking me
fucking any questions.
Um,
and I thought,
yeah,
I'm just the Guy Kimbo to be so,
and then the someone
else go short question.
They said this is how he
was holding the phone.
Um,
the Afghan show of the questions
that I had it ever since.
So just in case you can visualize it,
they said to him,
what would you do with James Thomson One?
And he said,
I'd hung myself.
And I thought,
wow,
that's the dumbest motherfucker
in the history of MMA productions.
The idea that you have one guy that's
the most important thing and banking
everything on him winning.
So stupid eggs,
culturally domino.
If you kicked that guy's ass,
it would have been awesome if
they left you in side control.
It have been awesome.
Just like it was awesome
for him when he won,
it would have been awesome for you.
Then.
You know,
you got to let the guy who's supposed
to win win when you're trying to just be
the most marketable.
You're like looking for
the most marketable guy.
You'd never going to have
a legit organization.
His organization,
his whole organization was,
it was essentially a corrupt organization.
That's,
that's what that is.
Uh,
um,
I'm writing a book at the
moment because the blogs,
I've gone so well,
I felt to himself,
I've got a fucking a lot beside
looking back at the different stories,
can I take the federal drinking
water and everyone loved it.
And a few more.
So I started thinking,
I've got fucking
that,
that [inaudible] stories are
very important story from
martial arts because that
made me angry.
I was watching that at
home and I was angry.
I was like,
this is crazy.
And I love Kimbo.
I think he's an awesome guy.
Yeah,
he's a great character.
I like watching him fight.
He won a boxing match recently.
He's been winning a lot of boxing matches.
I love that dude.
It's not that I wanted
him to win or you to win,
but I wanted fairness.
And you worked hard to get
to that position and you
were in a dominant position
and they stood you back up and you were
fucking tired and you've got cracked.
And they did the same thing with big
country when big country had our Lawsky
down.
He was working for a fucking
Komora and they stood him up.
I'm like,
are you crazy?
It was quite have on it.
Well,
um,
I watched 'em big country and he was
almost in exactly the same position as me
when he beat Kimball on the,
with the,
yeah.
And I felt,
uh,
you know,
kind of not mentioned or no,
I'm very close to the same position,
you know what I mean?
The only difference is he
went with the mountain.
He had a full amount of crucifix on by,
which I'm sure you could
have worked towards.
You had them on his back.
He was only going to get more tired.
There was a couple minutes to go right.
The thing without
fine.
It's not that I think they should have
stopped the fight for because he came
back and yet,
and he was Adam.
He rocked in the third round.
He didn't fucking up,
but I'm punches.
Um,
and I was,
I was walked.
So it's not bad,
but they should have sent
you might not me out.
I don't know.
I know man.
I took him down.
Right.
I don't know who the warm right.
That's the fucking,
the point of the fight.
You've got to let the fight you include.
He could've knocked me out.
Make Cause I was,
I was about one more take down and he,
and he was mine.
Will you take such a good shot and you
take so many shots that sometimes people
don't know what the fuck to do.
And I think a fight like that,
like you took some bombs from
Kimbo and you were still there.
And it's like the referees,
like,
man,
do I rescue this fucking guy?
It's a weird judgment call and it's very
important to have the right referee in
a situation like that.
Like a guy like herb dean,
he'll,
he'll let you fight,
he'll let you fight if he,
but he will save you if
he knows you're fucked,
you know?
And that,
that I think there's a lot of fights
where the referee errs on the side of
caution and protects the fighter.
And in a case like yours,
you feel like you were denied
an opportunity because of that.
Right,
right.
Well,
yeah.
Well what I was saying before,
so I was,
I take van Berlin,
but the,
I was backstage and it,
it just happened and I'm Gary Shaw Son,
um,
that fucking
Scala Skala what seems like
a nice guy with a fucking
dollar sign fucking is a
chain of dark side chain.
Yeah.
It's clever.
Well he grew up with the
rich dad and he both,
you know,
it's an interesting way to live your life,
but he came up to me and he said,
you've got to go to the hospital.
You've got to do it well to the hospital.
Now I know you've got
to go to the hospital.
Yeah.
I turned to him and I said,
yeah.
I said,
yeah,
but it turned her away or you know,
cause there was a lot going on,
so didn't hit me.
Then he turned back and went,
you have to go to the hospital
now I'm taking you now and I,
you really want me to go
to the hospital right.
Too much.
So then I went to the press conference
instead and as I walked into the patch
conference,
Garrett,
y'all was going,
we've just have to take James
Thompson to the hospital.
The
breathing to the,
I'm someone caught into it and I was
drinking their drink and I think out some
old man then that sums it all up there.
Correct.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's a corrupt organization.
That's horse shit.
They're pretending you were hurt
more than you were to pump Kimbo up.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
So it was hauling ass stupid
organization that was,
you know,
I don't make predictions man.
A very rarely make predictions,
but one of the predictions that I made
was when a lead XC mixed Seth purchase
Ellie up with Kimbo.
Okay.
I'm like,
well,
come south.
Petrocelli has been around a long time.
He's a seriously seasoned guy.
I'm like,
this is a terrible fight.
I bands heavy hands and
he's very aggressive and
especially in the first round,
like he's gonna come after you,
man.
You know,
he's had a bunch of injuries
and he's had a long career.
He's fought a long time.
But in that fight I was like,
boy,
I could see that as a mismatch.
That's a bad fight for Kimbo last minute.
They are so stupid.
The way they designed that organization
around one guy who was basically a
really exciting prospect.
He was a really fun guy.
He had a cool look,
you know,
I'm glad that he made some money.
I'm glad that he did well,
but the,
that you would bank at all
and this one guy based on,
no,
you made have him fight guys
too and pump them up to an exam.
I May.
It's almost unpredictable sport ever.
And now he's fighting boxers and you know,
I'm,
I mean he's,
he's got a bunch of knee problems as well.
So I mean,
he looks,
I mean the guy who fault,
I felt the guy was gonna win in the end.
I mean Kimbo did 12 to get the
petitioner shot and finish him.
Oh,
that was the last boxer.
Yeah.
That guy seemed a bit out of shape
about dangerous man following him,
following him.
And they were both gassed
in the first round.
We both fucked about sacramental.
He teed off on Kimbo one combination and
Timbo stiffened up towards the end of
the first.
He got tagged for clean
ones to covered away.
Thought he went for it too.
I'm the guy,
Ken both did well.
I got that under is finished.
It will kill.
Recovered.
Really Nice and a fight that was a,
that was impressive.
It was obvious that he's shaped,
it was a,
that was a crazy fight.
He's an,
he's an exciting guy.
It's not that I didn't want him
to win or wanted you to win,
but when they said you guys up,
I was like,
you guys are ruining the sport
because that's not the sport though.
I took it to the bank.
Yeah,
you don't know the individual
people have promoters,
man.
The arrogance of those boxing guys to
think that they could just come in and
just sort of work it the way they've
worked by it shows you how they've worked
box,
how they build up contenders and they're
not concerned as much about what you
can do as they are about how
much money they can make off you.
So it's not about we need to test
them against some strong competition.
It's about let's get him some setup fights
and let's avoid that guy because that
guy will explore.
It's possible.
Yeah,
I keep it going as long as possible.
Promoted all yourself.
Do it all internally.
This is don king's fighter.
I'm don king,
the promoter,
and you,
you know,
you get it to a point
where the guy's a champion,
then you fucking Rican into cash while
avoiding the dangerous guy that nobody
knows that will knock them out.
It's a fucking rocky movie.
Uh,
you can give them money.
The money you do make you put to good
use because you fund sucks up career.
Yes.
Who's free?
Who's rap career?
Oh yeah.
Scholar.
So Scott,
a rap crews.
You're good rapper.
Oh my
gosh,
I'm tired.
I just think it's,
it's,
it's very lucky.
We're all very lucky that
that organization doesn't
operate the way it did.
And then up Sydney's a,
if you're not saying these video,
no,
those are real rap video.
Yeah.
I said I don't make fun of the guy.
He's a young guy,
but he grew up with a
wacky dude for a dad.
I mean,
if that's your dad,
what the fuck?
I'd be a Douche bag
too.
That was my dad's.
How the fuck am I going to turn out?
This is my role model here.
Well,
yeah,
I mean you don't have to tonight like,
yeah.
In a young guy,
right?
Yeah.
Cause I mean like my mom had a
terrible upbringing and cheap,
the best ever.
Jeremy.
It sometimes works the opposite.
It's how to say his name.
I know what you mean.
Playing the odds.
Generally.
Gary Shaw's your dad.
Yeah.
I'm going to be an asshole.
Jen Yama Gemini.
I am.
Yeah.
I'm a Jew.
Harbor resentment from them after that,
when you knew that they
had stood there fighting.
I,
I did.
Um,
I did,
I used that in the wrong way,
the wrong way.
I act and I thought fuck it.
And then the blockhead dumb Merkley I to,
he fucked up from my mate most in,
uh,
he was roughing him.
I'm co poked most of the eye and most,
well,
uh,
and then who was it?
Um,
most of took,
he,
he uh,
he got poked in the eye by call cop and
then he didn't stop the fight and I was
like,
you fucking prick.
You know why?
Merga layout is the same one
that stood you up on with Kimbo.
Yeah.
Yes.
The same one.
We're all laughing.
They instructed them all to do that,
right?
Didn't they instruct the reference?
I don't.
That's a really tricky
situation and that's where,
you know,
it was a very famous clip of Dana White,
like yelling at the camera going,
that's fucking illegal
because that kind of shit,
you can alter the course of a fight.
And one of the reasons why it's
illegal because people bet on fights,
you know?
So you're essentially the Vegas,
it's legal.
Okay,
so you're,
you're fixing that fight.
If you're telling a guy that
he asked to go to the ground,
you know,
or you're telling you the
guy that he has to stand up,
you're,
you're altering what,
what he would or wouldn't have
done independently on his own.
You're essentially fixing the fine.
You believe if interviewed,
even if you're wrong,
you're attempting it.
And it should be illegal to have any
influence whatsoever on how the guy
performs in any other way
other than just saying,
hey man,
this is your best bet to
win this fight or clothes.
Anything else you tell them like,
what are you doing the fuck are you doing?
You're,
you're influencing the possible result,
especially if you're a promoter.
So for,
is it promoted?
It tells a referee they've
got to stand people up early.
That guy should be in jail.
Yeah,
the the out.
Um,
I mean,
I don't want to go into too much.
Well,
the judge who's I found
out the second round,
all the treasury,
Scottish ten nine to me,
the first phone,
the sacrament,
it was 10,
eight,
ten eight and then gallery shawls mate
who lives down the volt phone who go
shell was on the New
Jersey Athletic Commission.
That Guy Scott,
ten eight Kimball that second round.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Wow.
So you know,
just corrupt.
Yeah.
Light.
He's hates corruption and the aids and
he bought by the override it ten nine to
me.
I,
I think
there's a lot of salt though.
Just like,
just flip a coin at the
end of a round two though,
there's a lot of bad refereeing and MMA
or bad judging may more bad judging.
I think then referee,
there's a lot of really good referees,
but there's some standout bad judges
that keep turning in to like bad decision
after bad decision.
They're like,
you're crazy.
Like how do you see that fight like that?
Like that's nuts.
It's fucking nuts.
So many of them,
there's so fucking many of them.
There's a lot,
a lot of bad,
bad judging going on.
It's just doesn't make any sense to me
that you're talking about a sport that's
one of the most popular sports
at this point in the world.
Okay.
One of the most dangerous and one
of the sports that requires the most
commitment out of the athlete because
you're not just putting your physical body
on the line.
You're putting your emotional wellbeing,
how you feel about life.
You're putting a lot of shit on
the line and you are not partying.
You're not you.
You are.
You got to fine tune your weapon over
the course of eight weeks of long,
hard,
grueling fucking train and to have all
that judged by someone who's just totally
incompetent and is completely add
the loop as far as like transitions,
techniques,
the benefit of being in certain places,
the benefit of holding certain positions.
How do you,
how do you score round subjectively
when you're looking at like all the
different things that happen in the round.
If you don't know which ones are good,
how do you score that round?
What do you,
you just,
it's like you said it before,
but the system and that is an everything
you see that I went to a wrestling show
vastly show.
I went to like some,
uh,
my mate was wrestling Greco.
I'm freestyle asking like papa wrestling.
So he went not on the people.
Um,
I had a mate who's freestyle wrestler.
He wanted the Commonwealth Goldfinger
and he slapped the prospect.
Now we at the Olympics,
didn't wear the vessel.
Veselin bold them old fuckers who
battled a day in their life had free
wildcards.
One of them.
They're used for a woman who's a Russian
and the overtake Russian woman wrestler.
Yeah,
but the color,
but the color all of a sudden I'm hard.
I'm sure the bed she
had to to bed as well.
Of course she had a period Russian woman.
I heard you.
But the um,
the two of us,
the two of a wildcard,
she was saying use thinking
about any bridge people.
My Main Leon Volvo's,
it'd be like you say after that point
reminded me when you said it'd be
investing since he was a kid.
All the way you get the Olympics,
he's going to go and they don't use one
of the wildcards just don't use him.
Why?
He said unbelievable.
Well,
there's a lot of corruption in sports.
Think not even pop the Olympic town.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
That's the newest thing to happen
is that the Olympic Committee,
which has um,
figure skating,
right.
Isn't that in there you might
eat synchronized swimming,
synchronized swimming,
ping pong,
fucking no rumble,
humble,
all which are fine to Prac.
Yeah,
of course.
You enjoy doing the
decathlon good at home.
The idea that you can't have
wrestling in the Olympics.
The Olympics is based on,
it's one of the most
important sports in MMA.
You see on the most important,
the most important weapon in Mia.
The is the ability to control whether
or not a fight stays up or on the ground
that you,
if you're the better wrestler,
you can dictate one of the most important
aspects of fighting the fight takes.
And if you can enforce your game plan,
you're very likely to win.
Forget about MMA,
forget about MMA.
Wrestling for kids is one of the best
tools for character development of young
athletes because it is fucking brutal
and it's really about heart and
determination and it becomes about,
it becomes about your
will to push forward.
You're will to to make sure that you put
in the miles in the morning so that in
that second period you're the one who has
more energy and you get to take out to
Bolton.
Yeah,
there's so it's setting
goals and achieving goals.
Competition without worrying about like
getting knocked unconscious like boxing
competition or martial arts competition.
It's one of the most grueling
ways to test yourself,
but that they're doing that.
And Th th th the,
and I find that crazy building
a world full of posters.
We are building a world full of pussies.
We really are.
And the crazy thing is when a guy like
you says that they look at you and go,
this is fucking,
meathead wants everybody to be a
fight in the streets and not us.
No.
But there's a benefit to
character development that
a lot of people are missing.
And it's one of the reasons our world
is so conti is because men don't have to
be men anymore.
You don't have to develop character.
You don't have any like
real good feel like the,
the,
the way you carry yourself and the way
you live your life and the way you stand
up for things and the way you sort
of carve out your own destiny.
That's,
that's a part that's a
whole part of being a man.
And you benefit from any
test that your will gets.
You benefit from any new experiences
you can take on the situation.
Fucking bullet ants.
I think they're just don't
have the Internet yet.
They have the Internet.
They would cut that shit.
Right.
I'd just be jerking off all the,
if you gave the Amazon
people the Internet,
they'd be like,
oh,
get all those bitches suck in fall,
fall apart.
You mind with the fucking glove off?
No,
no la be painful.
Yeah.
You'd be really gangster if you jerk
off with a bulletproof bullet ant glove,
the next pass and that,
no,
not been a fan for
season for Adam Carolla.
The new hook.
Yeah.
The um,
the,
the note,
there's no way you could survive more
than a hundred bullet ants on your Dick.
I think you would just die even before
just knowing you have to do that task is
dying.
The transplant.
Maybe it was just,
if you don't know folks,
bullet ant is one of the most poisonous
ants in the world and Brian Cowen
described it to me.
That's one of my favorite ways
anybody's ever described it.
They say it feels like getting your,
if you get stuck in your arm,
like getting your arms slammed
in a car door for a day,
slam slam,
slam.
It's just insane pain that brings you
to your knees and it lasts like a day.
He's matching one in your Dick Hole,
rolling inside your Dick off and
then stings the root of your ball bag
and you're the VP of balls
swell up like grapefruits.
You can't walk to the grocery store.
You have to,
if to have people go food shopping
for you can't walk around,
but you could get one of those little
scooters and as long as you didn't fall
off,
you got disabled patch.
Yeah.
Get a one of those,
those fucking gyroscope things.
What are those things called?
Segues.
Yeah.
Those are supposed to be the shit.
At one point in time,
people thought that they were
going to take over the world.
They thought they were,
we weren't going to be walking
down city streets anymore.
Just be segwaying back and forth,
back and forth at the
same thing in England,
the Sinclairs thing,
c five,
which is now,
uh,
it was,
like uh,
you never heard of this in class?
He five of it?
No,
no,
no.
Not many people have,
what is it like in the 1976,
six little fucking car?
Uh,
which uh,
I think that might have a pedal wasn't
in front of be solar powered on,
but there were for fault fortune.
Now solar powered in the 70s.
Yeah,
I think so.
That's something they have
solar power in his seventies.
Still talking about a sunroof.
They have a sunroof warm.
So would you say that's it?
And a magnifying glass and a,
it would come down.
Yeah.
Burn.
You know,
I'm the African can't be pedals,
but Sinclair's he pipe.
But there were a lot of money now.
Really?
Well there were,
cause there's such a failure.
They know like a collector though.
It's a weird thing that we love.
Like a lot of old shit is that you go,
wow.
There we go.
So it looks like it's a panel.
Yeah.
Okay.
How do you steer?
So am I missing choir to ask
him if you asked six times,
so suck your Dick.
No,
no,
no.
So
who gets to never sex if you're oh seven.
And he guy that wears socks
like that will suck your Dick.
You just have to be persistent.
Well,
I'm sure all the other pictures,
the guys like Trump normal asking him,
nope.
Nope.
It's a gay pickup site
disguise as a bike car.
Wow.
There's a forum.
And on that forum they talk about
where they parked their bikes.
I parked mine by the big oak tree,
you know,
it would be near the highway goes,
all right,
I'll be dressed like a wizard
if I get dogging thing.
This guy's dressed like a wizard.
He's out riding his little bike.
Look at this guy.
I'm working for Harry Potter and he's
going to meet him in the woods and suck
his dick.
I can see it and I want to go there.
And they uh,
they changed the oil.
That's what it's called.
Changing the oil.
They have like their own little fucking,
maybe that's why it wasn't successful.
CMO change my oil.
He wrote that at the end
of that little posts,
you know,
lol,
CMO change my oil.
Okay,
where are we changing it right
behind the oak tree over here.
Oh boy,
I've got a leak in my old phone.
I said,
come on.
That's what that guy's doing.
It says kids,
a victim doesn't even know
what the fuck he's doing.
He goes,
I think those things
would be cool to drive.
Little did he know that he was getting
involved with some sort of a rest stop
cult car accident with a templates?
A girl.
Actually I think that's a girl is a girl.
Did she know that she
was getting involved?
Some rest area called.
Did you hear that the pope is
seeking immunity from prosecution?
Boy,
I started looking in
on some of this a pope.
Shit,
because so many people
are so upset about uh,
what he did when he was a cardinal
apparently or whatever the fuck he was.
Whatever magical title he,
he shielded people from child molester,
from child molestation charges.
One of them was a guy who
molested 200 deaf kids.
So they take this guy,
they take these people,
they put him into psychiatric care,
then gets out.
Well that's more kids,
Stryker,
it's fucking co Raese and the
pope shielded this guy too.
Took these people in many,
many cases,
there's been many cases of it took
these people and kept them away from
prosecution.
It's a terrifying,
terrifying story of how someone who,
the people,
the the,
I mean,
I think most people who are
Catholic probably have no idea.
Like how deep the organization goes with
its willingness to protect pedophiles.
They want to know.
I don't think they want to know either,
but they like to think of it
as it's part of being Catholic.
And the idea of being,
I,
I have a friend and like
I'm not a religious guy.
I don't,
I don't believe in religion.
I th I believe it's very possible
that there's a higher power.
But I believe that whenever you let people
write shit down and tell you what the
fuck is supposed to be done
and not supposed to be done,
you lost it all.
It's like people are corrupt.
They've always been corrupt.
Yeah.
And,
and you're talking about people that lived
a long time ago when we really didn't
understand the distribution
of information.
We didn't understand writing things down.
We didn't understand what you were
just telling each other stories for a
thousand years for anybody
even wrote that down on paper.
That's,
I can't,
I can't go with you on that.
Okay?
You can believe it if you like and
I see where you're coming from.
I,
it would be nicer.
It was true.
But that doesn't mean that the people
that choose to agree with that also choose
to agree with and child molestation and
all the shit that's going on that they,
they,
they are connected to the idea of God.
They're connected to the idea of,
of,
of sin,
religion.
They're not connected to the reality
of what these priests are doing.
So it's the fact that in
this day question it though,
don't they?
They do
lock them away,
but DEMEC it's an epidemic.
Okay.
If it was NASCAR,
race drivers,
fucking kids,
the shit would be closed
down a long time ago.
They've spent hundreds of millions
of dollars paying people off,
hundreds of millions of dollars paying
people off because they fuck their kids.
It's craziness.
It's not one case or two cases and was
money cases you don't know me don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know if someone offered
me money until this goes away.
I'm,
you know,
fall.
You got pimping out your child,
not just selling you a kid facade.
It's craziness.
It's ABS.
The whole thing is crazy,
but there's been many of these guys that
were shielded from prosecution because
the pope,
they should have been in jail.
In general population.
There's,
there's nothing holy about these people.
There's nothing pious about these people.
These are fucking sex criminals and
they're out there doing their thing.
Then they don't even
take their titles away.
Deviled made me do it and then
they don't even say that man.
They just sweep it under the
rug and say that there's,
there's been guys that have said that
the children have tempted the priests and
that unknowingly not even
knowing what they're doing.
Yes.
Funky bowls joke.
Frank boils a English correct.
What is it?
What does this joke?
He says,
why do a
download it?
Don't tell him,
but he says,
what a kid's all would go for
that type glossies and fucking as.
That's kind of funny.
Everybody.
Kids always go for the race type.
You know the this,
the fact that they're allowed
to wear those outfits.
That alone,
you can't allow anybody to ever have a
fancy name or wear a fancy outfit because
all they're saying with a fancy
name or a fancy outfit is,
I'm better than you.
I'm a general look at my fancy outfit.
Look at all my shit.
I am a king.
Look at my fancy outfit.
Look at all my fancy shit.
I got a fancy title.
I'm the pope.
Oh,
look at my fancy outfit.
Look at my fancy title.
You gotta leave me.
You're,
you're telling me you're a magic person.
you're telling me you have superpower
kick things telling me that you are
different from everybody else
that has to listen to you.
The kids just thinking he's Santa Claus.
You know,
that's what the whole Santa
Claus Pinkston a position.
Yeah,
it's,
well,
it's like that in a way because they
think he's in a position of being above
them because he's wearing a crazy outfit.
And when you're young,
those people,
you don't,
you haven't questioned
the whole world yet.
So when you see a guy that's wearing a
pope outfit and he wants you to suck his
Dick,
you know,
or,
or you know,
what one are those bishop outfits?
What are the,
if they're not the,
as the pope outfits,
right?
But these are,
these are,
there's a whole bunch of
stories of these guys who are,
they don't even lose their title.
There was an ABC news
report on it and see,
see if you can pull that up on the
pope and a pope and a child molestation
charges and he protected.
There's a crazy ABC news story about
it and it's really fucking frightening.
It's really frightening to think of how
much money is spent protecting these
priests.
And a lot of it is done under the
guise of if they can keep it quiet,
then they can keep the Business Cohen.
Yeah.
Because the Catholic
church is like a business,
you know,
like the,
the,
the Vatican is a giant business,
a huge business.
So when shit got too hot with this guy,
like,
listen man,
we need a new CEO,
you gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Why is that?
Why he's quit?
Because of that.
There's only one reason why he would
be trying to avoid prosecution.
Well,
there's two,
there's one,
there's some sort of a money scheme.
There's some sort of a
money laundering scandal.
There's like missing money or
missing or not placed money.
I don't know what,
what that's all about.
I Dunno if that's valid.
And then there's this,
and this is much scarier because this is
the guy who's at the highest level of,
of that position.
I mean,
he's a Po.
That's a,
that's a frightening thing
to think someone could get
to that position and have
avoided what the laws are and w you know,
and but just what natural though,
his moral compass,
it should be that a
person who a pedophile.
It's not,
you don't put them into just psychiatric
care and moving to a new place where
they can molest children.
He put him in jail.
They're criminals.
They've,
they've,
whether or not there,
sorry.
That's beside the point.
That person is victimize someone and the
law is such as when someone does that,
they're supposed to be locked up.
Just like murder.
Just like robbery.
There's a lot of laws.
Okay.
And you can't shield someone from that
law because they wear a fancy outfit.
That's,
that's crazy.
That's bananas and that can't keep going.
It just can't.
And it's much like what we
were talking about like kings,
you know,
I mean the thing that
Jeremy Sophal in England,
I found out goals and I
tell you to call it that.
Yeah.
And you put it,
by the way,
my friend Steve,
who's English was just telling
me this story this weekend.
I wasn't aware of it.
And I bet a lot of people
who are listening to this
also weren't aware of it.
Tell the Jimmy Savile
story as best you can.
I'll help.
I'll decipher some of the shit you say
like subtitles because your accent is it,
would you call it cockney?
No,
that's London.
What is your accent?
Melvin?
I'm a novelist and northern Munkee.
Okay,
so this Jimmy Savile,
that's how you say his name.
He was a huge popularity the first of
a nightclub in the 70s the first ever
night club kind of,
and he was talking about it.
So first have a nightclub I used to Dj,
then when I'm top of the
pope's Benny Hod Gmo fix it,
we fix it was a huge television show,
right?
We're all working with kids.
So this guy would like having
to be sitting on a chair,
like a king kid sitting in
his lap and you a metal Jim.
What do you hope fixed it for you?
Yeah.
And you're fucking vape budge.
Right.
And this guy apparently had
just molested hundreds of kids.
Well and the BBC knew about it.
Was that the whole scandal,
how much should they know and how
much it also not only did not also,
not only was it like,
ah sorry.
No need for that.
So not only did they know about it
that not only do they know about it,
they uh,
you know,
he speaks English.
So I'm like trying to
help them with anything.
That's not a good sign.
I mean,
something about during
Joe's lounge chairs go,
you got it.
I'm sorry.
So Jenny Saville he did,
he did a lot of chow evens it,
there a lot of things like that.
And he did them things to get the
publicity and he got his own ward on a
children's hospital,
a mental hospital so he
could stay the night.
And that's what he did.
He did these Ramzan anyone say anything
even we like proper play him off.
So they'd say,
well okay,
you can say something but you
won't be getting x amount of check.
Try to do the one for
this or the gun for that.
So a lot of people knew
that something was going on.
He was molesting people and
it was a neck failure and,
and neck were feeling that site.
And I'll tell you,
well that's how,
that's how I sound now.
The Colossus says that guy.
How did he get dead bodies?
Oh,
because he was at the hospital.
They had the keys.
He had everything.
He had a old come to fall.
Oh,
okay.
I need to open an office.
Put those names in the royal family.
You so many pictures of
him with the royal family.
He was like proper,
proper French with him.
He was over the little over the
picture of him with a lot viral family.
Thought out some kids.
Well two little kids and left.
You imagine he's a pedophile.
Necrophilia cause like he
probably was fucking kids.
It's like this is not evil.
And I
look on Youtube,
right?
For um,
there's a,
there's a clip or it's molesting,
um,
like a famous band.
There's a lady
to what we call,
what is his name?
Jimmy.
Top of the pops.
Subtle spell it.
I might be wrong.
Jimmy Savile molests all fields up,
fields up top of the pops.
There's fit.
She's filling up one of these.
Uh,
I can't remember the fucking air we go.
I'm saying,
uh,
they signed that check.
Turn the volume up here.
He's,
it's a creepy fuck it too.
I mean,
if you look at him is every,
it's like,
hey,
did I each man it be the one
who broke to balk at it.
It's so much for other stars and
over people to fuck children.
He was mad.
He was meant to be the man.
Well,
that's one of the things.
Oh,
there he is.
Look it up
when all the can says goodnight from
all the top of the thoughts and there's
number one time.
And of course he would leave me.
Now it's from the one and only,
Eh,
she car go.
What was he doing?
I don't know.
I guess he had his finger
up her like a oh yeah,
pink sauce.
Oh,
the one in the yellow.
The play did it again.
Look,
he's like grabbing at her that,
that's not even the one
I was talking about.
That's a different one.
I answer.
Oh my God.
Well,
blame them.
A bunch of checks.
You got a little crazy isn't too bad.
It's when you say that all the young kid
and that's a woman to this on a child
and apparently he did this
to a bunch of children.
He had hit a fucking show by this.
If you pull up Jim,
we'll fix it.
Brian.
It's really crazy.
I mean you seem like you had like these
children's scattered around them and
sitting on his lap.
Yeah.
These men,
apparently the people knew about it.
They knew he was doing it.
The people around them.
It's like,
that's my childhood.
Well,
no,
that's not my child.
That's like,
he was that Jim will fix it was big then.
Oh Man.
Everyone was like [inaudible] how
long did this go on for fucking ever?
He died and no one knew about it.
No one knew about it.
But he says,
what year?
Uh,
doesn't say.
Does it say on the top?
Like you know the information.
Wow.
What year was this on?
All the way for the
seventies and eighties right?
Yeah.
Wow.
You don't know this this way.
Was it a surprise?
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
She said that you had to pick your group
and pose because you didn't believe
what was happening.
Is that right?
Yeah.
What were your shelter have?
We won't have we won or we won
or we came to the arms.
There you go.
No,
you're not going to be on Jim.
I'll fix it now.
Sorry.
I'm afraid we can't fix it because
anybody would go spend pose.
It still happens.
Come on,
Jim will fix it.
You got goose pimples.
Come on.
I'm sorry.
It wouldn't be like,
take a fucking your soul.
The focus is what's her name?
Okay.
What has Johnny Carson Nice to twin peaks.
One's name is prime.
So if you could give him a
pat on them that is your,
that and everyone knows Santa Claus is
not talk like that and that camera is
going to bite.
That kid's fingers off.
How about that?
Wow.
I'd look to raise
a special presence.
Boy,
the Van Damme,
unless I love how it says drug jail.com
is it people that are holding the what
the fuck is?
Wow.
So that guy was a huge,
huge celebrity.
No one had any idea.
I'm not,
well,
a lot of people at an
idea and that's just it.
How many people knew?
That's the big thing now,
but the public as well as a whole,
isn't it amazing how many stories like
that turn out to exist and how many
secrets actually get capped with
horrible situations like that?
Like the Jerry Sandusky thing,
they,
they kept that a secret for a long time
and it wasn't like a little secret.
Like,
ah,
Graham,
my bigger,
I'm from my machine or shrink or sneakers.
It wasn't that.
No,
no,
no.
It was,
he was fucking a gang of
kids and everybody knew it.
And somehow or another he got away
with it and that's why we'd come.
Suppose he's,
I think he can keep secrets.
Yeah.
You know,
there was a guy who investigated
Jerry Sandusky that disappeared too.
There's a prosecutor,
they found his laptop without
the hard drive in a river.
Never found him.
Yeah,
he fucking,
Sia disappeared.
They,
they,
they killed the guy investigating.
And I asked my friend Joey,
it was like Joey Diaz.
I was like,
why would they do it?
He goes,
you know how much fucking money
is involved in college sports?
And so he pulls up like all
these stats on college sports,
like how much the alumni get,
like how much,
uh,
the,
like a,
a college can get from people donating.
People that used to go there,
it's billions of dollars.
It's crazy money.
It's ridiculous how much money it is.
And um,
that's sort of the same
thing with the Vatican.
It's sort of the same thing
with this BBC program.
There's a lot of people making money
and nobody wants to fuck it up.
Same thing,
Jerry Sandusky.
It's the same thing.
It's like somehow or another people can
spire to allow horrible things to happen
to children.
Just don't think about it.
Well,
that's,
I don't know that it's not
that they don't think about it,
it's that they think about money more
than they think about what's right.
The only,
I mean,
at this point in time,
there's,
there's no way anybody can,
I mean,
it's not like you're shocked when you
hear about a priest molesting each kit.
No,
no one's shocked.
You're angered,
you're sad,
and you're,
you're horrified,
but you can't,
like,
I don't believe that's not possible.
It's not possible.
If you found out,
like say that Brad Pitt
was a child molester,
that you'd be devastated.
He'd be like,
how the fuck?
That's not,
that's it.
Makes Sense.
That's nuts.
But you hear about that
a priest is doing it.
You're like,
that's the pattern.
That's the pattern.
Yeah.
They're the ones that do it.
It's,
it's,
it comes up a lot.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if it's all of,
I'm sure it's not all of them,
but man,
it's a lot of them,
you know,
I'm sure there's a good percentage of
priests out there that are in it for the
right reasons and doing the right things.
But if there was that many Kinko's
copied workers that fuck kids,
when they shut down
Kinko's as an illegal kid,
fucking organization,
when they go in and look at
what's going on here and go,
what are you guys doing?
You're making envelopes and hockey.
His fucking Cockins.
What's happening?
One of them's got to go,
Alecia.
And at least Kinko's
has a fucking business.
They actually provide a service,
you know,
these crazy foxer telling Mumbo
jumbo and blowing little kids,
Christopher Hitchens,
he was fucking wicked on me.
Yes,
he was brilliant.
Brilliant man.
He got the Evoque all Vong alternate.
Well,
he became a bit of a neo-con I think a,
a lot of older,
more conservative guys.
Uh,
especially people that,
uh,
Lowe's,
radical fundamentalist religions,
you know,
which he did.
He felt like it was important to have
that sort of a strong military stance
against the tyranny of
the religious world.
I don't agree with that as well either.
No,
I think it's,
it's all,
I mean,
when you have that kind of
power ultimately corrupts
and when you allow people
to just go into countries and
under the guise of doing that,
you got to get a gang of corruption and
chaos and craziness like they have in
Iraq right now.
I mean,
I racked right now it's fucking bananas.
it's more unstable than
it's ever been before.
What is I Afghanistan like
that's fucking crazy too.
The more you look into it,
the more you say you bought.
He just,
what do people want to know?
People
one on one.
I've got busy.
They've got nine to five.
You've got no time for an event.
No time.
And it's all the way over there.
Miles or James Thompson.
We're not going over there.
I worry about that.
Stay over here and get a burger.
Sit back.
Relax.
Yeah.
No,
I'm not saying he's so easily done.
So you're not fighting for
the Superfight league anymore?
No.
Who you,
uh,
who are you fighting for now?
Nolan one.
Now you a it training.
Any more specific?
Not,
I'm trying to Olympians.
I'm potty Johns.
I'm not feign.
Um,
Bristol was tweeting out London.
Shoot fighters.
Great team.
But I needed to get into
London with my gambling.
And so you know Marius [inaudible].
Oh yeah,
I did.
Yeah.
You mentioned a few times he's,
yeah.
I said Hi.
Yeah,
we'll,
I'll do to all the guys.
They are,
they are wicked.
Yeah.
Do you know when you tell
the story about Germany?
Yeah.
That's really great car.
Listen to the podcast all the time.
I'm massive fan.
I'm going to hear that story.
I was at that fight with Moss.
I was at that hotel.
I must have,
I seen you a breakfast spot.
You've got lots of people.
I didn't want to bother you at all.
I didn't say anything.
And then,
um,
on that night I was coming home fucking
really pressing the button for the
elevator and Allie,
Eddie Bravo was her and
he's eyes or so fucking bad.
I think that's all I could see you.
It's like redness and I,
it's like I got it.
But it's just weird when
you tell that story,
you saw it,
you like tiny sliver of it,
you know,
new gone for folks.
You don't know the story.
Eddie,
Eddie Bravo and I were
staying in Germany once
and I,
I was getting breakfast.
It was like,
I don't know,
seven in the morning
or something like that.
And our flight,
we were getting picked
up at like eight 30.
So I called him up and I said,
hey man,
I'm getting some breakfast if a,
if you're hungry,
I'm downstairs.
And he goes,
Hey,
I'm still up man.
I'm going to power through.
He was up all night.
I was like,
okay,
you know that we're getting
picked up at an hour and a half.
I got it,
man.
I got it.
I'm cool.
I'm like,
all right,
shit.
So now and a half goes by.
I'm like,
why the fuck is Eddie?
I can't find him.
He's not answering the phone.
I'm,
I go to his room,
I knock on his door.
He's not in his room.
Go outside.
And I'm like,
motherfucker,
where is he?
And then I go,
all right then I'm just going to tell
him he's going to have to take a cab to
the airport when he wakes
up cause I got to go.
I'm not gonna Miss My fucking
flat if I can't get ahold of them.
So I go,
go to get my car.
I said,
yeah,
I'm a car for Rogan.
He goes rogue and already left and I go,
what?
I go,
what did he look like?
Cause long hair tattoos.
I'm like,
mother fucker.
He said,
he told him he was me and got in my
car and went to the airport on his own.
He's did this all blacked out trunk,
so I call him.
His phone rings and he
wakes up and he and he like,
he answers it.
He's like,
hello?
I go,
what the fuck are you doing?
I don't know.
And I go,
I go,
you're in my fucking car,
and you go into the airport,
tell him to turn around and go in it.
He's like,
I think we're already here.
I'm like,
fuck man.
What are you doing?
He woke up.
He had no idea what he did.
He asked the guy who was,
where are we?
Where are we going to guys like
you told me you go to the airport,
you know Joe Rogan,
Eddie Bravo could fucking party,
man.
He knows how to put them away.
He knows how to let it go.
I'll tell you that.
I used to work for the UFC to,
yeah,
he did a bunch of different
things to the UFC.
One of the things he did was for a while,
and I really think this was a,
someone needs to do this and
that he's really good at it.
Someone needs to do an objective breakdown
like Harold Letterman style of how
they felt the fight went down.
I think it behooves the organization
to have a professional ring side
statistician or a ringside rather a judge
like an unofficial judge like Harold
Letterman has in the Hbo and
Eddie Bravo did that for a while.
But I think,
um,
there was an issue with him and like his
opinions wouldn't necessarily go with
how the judges scored the fight.
And I don't think the
commission like that,
I don't think the state athletic
commission enjoyed having someone.
Essentially it was a professional critic,
so they wanted to,
they didn't want that.
And so especially with a new sport,
you have to make some concessions.
So they decided not to have it anymore.
But I,
I personally think that it is a good,
it's good in two ways.
It's not that I want people to
get fired who are her competent.
I think people were competent,
should stay,
but people were incompetent,
should be exposed.
It should be highlighted.
It's,
it's very important.
And the idea that their
job is more important.
There's silly,
easy job that they're not really qualified
for is as important as a person like
yourself that's puts six,
eight weeks of your life,
day in,
day out grind,
watching your diet,
doing the work for this one moment that
gets ruined because someone doesn't
understand what the fuck they're doing.
That's craziness.
And one of the best ways
to expose that as like how,
how Harold Letterman does
it and Harold Letterman is,
you know,
if there's a bad decision,
he will tell you,
I don't know
the standard.
I had it down 94 points a Jones,
there's no way he
could've lost this fight.
Plus hopefully like you say,
well Tony,
you need,
you need it.
And that's why they don't want to.
So Eddie did that for awhile and uh,
then he,
uh,
he also would do the,
when you put together like a highlight
package in the end of the round,
you know,
like when a guy like say guys,
go,
go for a submission.
Okay.
Eddie would tell them,
you got to get the camera over here.
Like,
where's risks is,
this is what's important.
Yeah.
And then he would say,
you know,
like he would like help
them cover the highlights.
He would be in the truck in
the truck and it was called.
And like sometimes he would
tell me something too.
Like he would let go,
hey look for got for his left arm.
He's going for a triangle
or something like that.
Yeah.
Cool.
And you know,
he'll like,
he would give me like a pointer here and
there and point out certain things if
you saw things.
But he was basically there to coordinate
the highlight reels and tell them where
to put the camera,
which was very important.
Have to mark della grotto does it now.
And it's,
you need a guy who has
been around fighting and
understands where there's a pro
and like he knows how to put
together the highlight reel.
Like he knows like it was the jab
that started off wash the jab,
makes his knees buckle and then he lands
the leg kick and then it comes to the
high kick cause he'll,
he'll like mark will like do that now.
He's,
he worked for pride to Eddie Bravo.
Yeah,
he did.
He was um,
one of the color commentators for pride
for a few events and he also did king of
the cage.
He did,
um,
the color commentary for King of
the cage for a bunch of events.
They were hauled some.
Yeah,
it's fun to see the key.
The cage one.
Yeah.
Well that's what I was going to bring up.
It was raining out and so
they just said fuck it.
Have the fights anyway.
It was outside.
If you haven't seen it,
it's worth getting.
If it's available,
if you can find it somewhere.
She in the cage went wild.
It was,
it was fucking ridiculous.
It's completely ridiculous.
Yeah.
It was literally slept in,
there was one wild flying
all over the place.
And I mean if you're a wrestler,
good,
good luck holding onto a guy
who's like completely soaks.
I mean people are just slipping out of
that dude's hand's like bars of soap is
that it was bad.
It was coming down and t yeah,
I fucking mental.
Well those were the days,
man.
You know and you are part of the the,
the,
those are the days too
with your pride fights man.
I mean you are part of some epic shit.
You are a part of pride when
it was like at its peak.
What was that like man?
Then what was the atmosphere,
lack of those events?
Who?
Soccer coach shock like
obviously in Japan itself,
different Joe.
I mean just everything so different.
And
I remember coming out to fight
and I'm like we said earlier,
I'd be fighting long and you know,
coming up for a fucking helmet,
I cannot be fighting in
front of 2000 excuse me,
two phase people and you know,
walking out in their fucking leisure
centers and then walking out for fucking
Lyft full of smoke and lights and
fucking walking for some of my helmet to
Jonah.
I mean who fucking alleys.
It's a lot to take in.
What was the biggest crowd
that you were falling under?
I paid 60 but they always
say it's more on us.
And they said about
80,000 cyber collect 60,
60,000 hours or I've seen that before
at the Roger Center in Toronto.
We had a UFC there and it
was somewhere around 60,000.
Between 58 yeah.
It's so,
it's so crazy.
And you're looking around and you're like,
this is all a lot of fucking people
and these points in the Japanese,
everyone's quiet,
quiet people.
I am not because I am,
but on the lights went down because
they have a guy who was getting it.
Um,
I can't remember was it was,
it was,
it was coming in and the lights
went down on a com Hannifin.
Allow shy kid.
Fuck you.
I'm not dreaming.
No.
So it did dry,
don't block.
And then the fucking lights come back
on and you think in fact came out.
Maybe go,
am I dreaming?
Wow.
Punched in the face and you think,
no,
I'm going watch.
It must have been especially crazy for
you because how many fights did you have
outside of pride?
Um,
I had,
I felt,
well I don't know what 10th,
11,
12 footing if I have quite a few,
I think in a shelter at time,
I was just getting 10 or 11,
13 point 12,
13,
five yards for pride.
Hopefully give,
I'll tell you that's a lot of fights
to have over a year and a half.
I was literally living it
to the gym and I was like,
this is what my Dave Wow,
I'm just fucking fall off going
everywhere and just training my ass.
And you see the difference in my,
uh,
in my,
in Mike and a fiscal,
my fitness and not like from my
first fight to maybe my full fight.
I look completely different.
I'm sure.
Completely different.
Cause what is the getting
drunk with fate or story?
Uh,
I uh,
it was fault.
Fuck.
I remember well eat beat Mike.
Come on.
Uh,
I'd come home and I was fucking pissed
and I seen the federal or the in the
hallway in the other perception
when he tends to see me.
Well talk to hope.
So,
so,
so when,
when he turned around and saw me,
I started swaying like just fucking vape.
You know what I mean?
I then he was like,
ah.
So then I went over to
type of wrestling with me.
Then I started fucking
about wrestling and I,
oh,
in a minute he's going to assemble
my fucking cold marble thinking,
please don't fucking don't please
don't fucking play me down.
But yeah.
And then he brought me down to have
a drink with all these rallies.
Mushroom flood or May,
whatever.
Putin.
No,
no,
no.
This has been prior to this in Japan,
it flood to me.
Fuck.
Maciej Center.
Like he's fucking manager
potentially.
Perfect.
I was his manager.
Yeah.
Oh,
Vadim.
If that do you think Olstein Oh God,
you'll see fighter.
The janitor.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I forgot got mixed up pants and only that
clamps it till I got the wrong fucking
person.
But doesn't put in,
come to his fights too.
Like yeah,
it's a huge superstar in Russia.
I mean,
people didn't know.
I'm amazed.
So massive safe style.
Jasmine fader and his peak man
was one of my all time favorites.
Some of them I time favorites.
He was just,
it was just so special like he,
cause he was so stoic and I like
this like just dead faced killer.
And if you go back and you
watch like the highlight fights,
like Nogueira fights,
cro,
cop,
like when he was like really
like at his very best man,
he was exceptional.
Very,
very fun to watch.
He really,
I mean like I used to anyone seen that
many times so fucking Vendome and slump
and incredible.
I namely relaxes and then
comes back and he's late.
He's got key lock.
How did he survive that?
So relaxed body soul relaxed but just
to avoid injury to get slammed like that
and avoid injuries.
Incredible.
He just didn't want it anymore.
He just lost.
He lost.
Why don't you tell us what
competition's getting better?
Bigger guys?
Well I think you can only
keep up that certain though,
that Rpms,
that certain sort of
workload that he was at.
You can only keep that up
for a certain amount of time.
There's,
there's issues with the body,
the body breaking down
after combat sports have,
you know,
10 15 years unless you're
Randy coture who's just,
I don't know how he did it,
but whatever he did,
he managed to avoid injury.
The one thing that no one avoids,
people who you know have
competed in mixed martial arts.
If you look at like issues like along
the way like guys who have broken hands,
guys who have had this guys ever had,
that guys are toward knees.
Guys who like kit to neck operations.
So many guys,
Randy didn't need chant.
No one broken arm and a fight when
Gonzaga Gonzaga broke his arm or the kick,
he got his own guy,
he had his arm in a cast,
no big deal.
You know,
six weeks later he's fucking
hitting the speed bag.
You know,
it's like,
how's that guy avoid injury?
It's an amazing man.
No,
no intelligence,
toughness,
genetics.
There's like a whole bunch
of things like working.
It's wet,
but it's really incredible.
But for most guys holding
a certain amount of time,
you can operate at a high
level before you just,
you lose your drive for it and politics
and life gets in the way and he got
super religious to fit or,
um,
got a really,
it's,
it's actually not even fade or do
you know that's what we call it.
It's,
it's fuel door.
Yeah.
My Russian friend of mine from was just,
it was explaining,
how do you actually say his name?
It's fuel door.
Fuel door.
Yeah.
Like [inaudible] you know,
it's like,
that's like we can't fade
art because it's easier.
Yeah.
The art kind of be honest.
Fuel door fade or sounds better.
Feel Doris A.
Little.
So break it.
The Russians would do crazy language.
He was such a nice guy though.
He was the guy at the top all the time,
you know,
always at time.
[inaudible] it wasn't like an
eight lane London personnel.
He just kept very quiet.
Do you want me at the time for everyone?
I'm like,
wow.
Do you know what I mean?
You really,
I really have a lot of a lot of time for,
he's an unusual dude.
I like,
his demeanor was just so different
than anybody that I'd ever been around
before.
That was one of the things that
was kind of special about them.
It's like we,
we had been used to so
many different things.
We'd used to certain boxers.
It had certain charisma about them,
whether it's Muhammad Ali or
sugar ray Leonard or Mike Tyson,
they have this certain
cult at aura about him.
He was different than all of them.
He was like,
Oh,
here's this new thing from a
guy who plays chess and uh,
it doesn't get freaked out at anything
and keeps his stone and just beat your
ass.
You know,
like,
here's this new look or a guy seems
like he's kind of a robot or something.
It's like that.
And he manages to smash like really
tough guys managed to walk down cro cop.
He beat Cro cop,
not just on the ground.
He beat him standing up dead.
Yeah.
Soak fucking quick so quick.
He's,
he's an animal and he
fucking trained really smart.
You trained to really
smart and really hard,
but even then,
like they started questioning his,
his,
his training methods and this,
you know,
after,
uh,
he went over to affliction and fought
those fights and then the strike force
shit,
he just gets smashed
man over and over again.
Just getting smashed by Henderson
and getting smashed by big foot.
You know,
watching those fights and watching those,
those brutal beat downs just gotta go,
man,
it's hot.
Yeah,
he's fucking hot.
Especially that's your big foot fight.
Yeah.
Well especially if I hate money.
So you still went in?
Yeah,
just the way,
even Brett Rogers like prairie
ranch just put up a good fight.
It was a good cause,
a good tough fight and you know,
fatal or eventually caught
him and cracked him.
But man,
you gotta look at that fight and go like,
he's not supposed to struggle
like that with Brett Rogers.
Understanding not the same guy anymore.
He just still got to remark
on when I'm off to the store,
what am I are they just took a lot.
They did a little bit.
My cotton had him on the ground
and had his arm locked up in a,
in a,
um,
Kamora but didn't,
couldn't pull it off,
couldn't do anything with it,
but it was a crazy how
he was able to do it.
Like he was able to get his arm
even and even have it locked out.
Yeah.
That's so bold.
And if for doom,
obviously exposed,
not exposed,
but expose the fact,
when I say exposed the fact that Schumann,
I mean everybody thought he was just an
unstoppable robot and all of sudden the
Verdugo exposed them as a human.
Yeah.
Come tapped him.
And when I say exposed,
have great respect
for Fado.
It's not like when I say people
giving me shit from saying that the,
but the is absolutely not.
When I mean,
when I say he was exposed,
what I mean was that we found out he was
human because anybody for BC over doom
catches in.
His triangle is fucked.
That guy is a master at the triangle.
And that triangle Armbar
was nasty and Fado is stock.
He had a tab.
Nothing wrong with that.
But what we thought before was that at,
that could never happen.
It seemed like he was a superhero.
He seemed like he was like,
like Mike Tyson,
when he lost a buster Douglas,
nobody thought Tyson was going to lose.
We thought Tyson was going
to be around forever,
just destroying people.
And then when he got destroyed,
you're like,
what?
This can't be real.
And he was exposed and it's not that he
was one of the greatest fighters of all
time.
Mike Tyson is absolutely one of
the greatest boxers of all time,
one of the greatest heavyweight champions,
the most exciting of all time.
But he's exposing that
fight as a human being.
That's not as a bad fighter.
He's amazing.
But that's a human and every human is
subject to the laws of physics and nature
and,
and you know,
and you could only,
you know what I mean?
You can only go so far
and just meet vehicles.
Yeah,
I think,
I forget the mental side of it too,
which I don't know,
but I just think federal didn't
up the same drive anymore.
I think it's hard to keep
up after all those years,
you know,
years and years and years
and years or card training,
being away from your family.
And again,
he got really religious too.
Why are you doing it?
I do it.
Test Yourself.
Why you're doing it from [inaudible] I,
you know,
we're doing it to be number one,
we'll your,
it's behind it,
you know,
it fucking out six hot.
Yeah.
Physically and it's,
it's to to keep it up to get their
unbelievably hard to keep it up as on
believable and to keep it
up for as long as he did.
It's all,
you only have a certain amount
of Rpms that you can push for.
There's only like a certain amount of,
especially in like a crazy
situation like cage fighting.
You got to think there's only a certain
amount of times and man I can get hit.
So like certain amount of times and
Maggie can get thrown armbar kicked.
It's only,
there's a finite number in there
somewhere and he's a smart guy.
He has to realize that a certain
point in time and then we're doomed.
And then big foot and then Henderson.
It's like,
like,
okay.
You know?
Yeah.
What a legacy though.
Well like I said,
what know they were trying to
put together Brock Lesnar and,
and uh,
and fader really recently.
The UFC was,
but uh,
he doesn't want to do it anymore.
I mean,
whether,
I don't know.
Oh,
through lifestyle photo.
Don't want to do it.
Cause I don't think
Paul last night was two,
two,
I'll pay Brock Lesnar would have done it.
Do you think so?
Yeah.
They offered him a fuck load of money.
I bet he would've done it.
Yeah,
I can help him.
He looked like he didn't want to.
He looked like to me.
I mean,
he got the surgery,
my safe.
That was a huge issue for folks who
don't know you had diverticulitis and uh,
they like 12
inches of his colon is a very
serious internal surgery.
It was a real injury.
And then x amount of months later,
however,
was he's fighting Alster overcome and
Overeem Nizam in the body and kicks him in
the body and have an Overeem
kick you in the body.
Like,
Ugh,
Jesus Christ to me before he,
I think he was thinking about the fine.
I forgive it's Wade.
I mean you're obviously worried about
every five buffer gives even more cause I
don't from Iso I'm,
when,
when came be him,
he turned his back.
Well then when come
out Shane Carwyn Scott,
I'm standing as well.
I mean I think personally Brock Lesnar
is one of the greatest athletes ever
enter into MMA.
I really do.
I just think that if
it was going to do it,
what he did is what you did.
Just jumped right into the,
what he did.
He was even crazier.
He was fighting Frank May second five,
second five second fight.
Fuck man.
He basically puts you and ask you to it.
But he pulled it off yet.
But yes,
he did the same.
Very similar path.
Even harder.
Much,
much,
much harder path.
No doubt about it.
Came to the last case.
Shane car when Frank Mir,
no.
Dot.
Randy coture.
I mean it's fucking
careers at Alster over him.
His career is filled with
champions and when you,
you know,
you look calm,
refined.
He,
he's not like,
he can take a punch for that.
Went out the eyeball on our flex
over drop me and he came back to win
convincingly.
Well he's fine with heath herring,
you know,
fight the UFC is third fight in the UFC
and the UFC seasoned veteran in a tough
motherfucker.
He's hearing is tough as shit.
And Brock Lesnar just random over.
Yeah,
this is a guy that was a super athlete,
but he would have had to,
in order to do it really truly correctly,
he would have had to build up slowly.
He would've had to do it intelligently.
And we did how to do it over a a quite
a long period of time and he should have
fought the right amount of
competition along the way.
Instead,
he went right to champions.
He went right to the greatest
fighters in the world today.
It went to Cain Velasquez,
Overeem indicted.
He was a chain carbon and he was
just right into these animals,
you know.
Whereas if he had gone for a few years
in the lower lower organizations building
up,
you know,
trying to,
fight,
fight for some other companies,
get a good record against some good
fighters and then put together like a real
striking game,
you know,
without the wall.
That was the thing because he had power,
the explosive fucking challenge.
I mean but,
but he did want,
that's how he wanted to do it.
He did it his way and he's out.
No I'm fucked.
Played Trim,
play term.
But too bad though because when
it comes to like making money,
like if you want to make
money off of a draw,
you think Kimbo slice of the draw.
Brock Lesnar is a fucking draw.
That's a guy that people
want to see fight.
I mean he looks like the baddest
motherfucker in the world.
You know,
we see him standing there like
if you're going to have a guy,
he big viking looking
motherfucker,
that would be the guy that you
would want to have represent you.
I'll talk to you though
to sort of this chest.
I lost it,
man.
Mine,
but I have to break it to him slowly.
I think at the very least I would,
uh,
Ryan Kelly's working for that show,
tattoo nightmares where it's,
they take tattoos and they go
on the show and they change,
they fix it for you to get a reality show.
And she's like,
she contacted me.
She's like,
do you know any MMA fighters that want,
you know,
habitat too.
They don't want to get
fixed or anything like that.
And I'm like,
I have no idea.
The only one I can think of is Brock.
She goes,
I must contact Brock.
And so now she's like,
contact
broke my nose.
No,
leave him alone.
Don't even say anything.
Why did you say Brock?
Because it's the only one
that came to mind that like,
you know,
when you see that one tattoo,
it kind of looks like a statue or
you think you should change it?
Does he think he should train?
No,
I don't think he does.
That's what I told her.
I was like,
I think that's the only
one I could think of.
You know,
it's like little mermaid
before they edited the cover.
Yeah.
I don't think he would appreciate
you saying that no two sucks.
No,
I'm not saying it sucks.
It looks like a cock at all,
Joe.
Yeah,
I didn't say that.
No,
you did say that.
Didn't say that.
That's what's important.
Didn't neither one of us did.
So
it looks like,
yeah.
Well I think like he was
at a point in his life.
I think though his a description of it,
like he felt like he had
a knife to his throat,
so he just fucking
tattooed one on his body.
That's what I've heard.
You know,
I can't,
you know,
like I say,
I've got fucking dates
crossed out my fucking arm.
Do I do,
I mean,
so you're not gambling it all now?
Is that the deal?
Well,
last time,
I mean that's,
I'm doing a documentary on them.
I basically,
I was doing the documentary,
I gambled all the rest of my money,
my me and my missus money and
I ended up living in the gym.
Uh,
yeah,
it was fucking freezing.
God Damn on.
Um,
so,
so I was living in the
gym on a mattress on a,
like an offer.
Look,
people offered me to stay of a place he's,
but I knew I needed something
big to get me back into training.
I was humming to 45 kilos.
I would say 10 pounds.
It's like 300 pounds plus pounds.
Yeah.
Low like free fatty or something.
I mean,
and I'm not going to,
why eve?
I've been the IVP foppish being
muscle out or mostly muscle.
Vicious foc.
Like on adult to eighth.
Pure Fun.
I was in the gym living on the living.
Yeah.
Living on a mattress on a than
I have at the documentary side.
What's going to be starting out on a four.
Okay.
We'll fill it in there.
Just stop doing it.
I tried game.
Okay.
Good footage and getting more confident.
And then,
you know,
the only thing good I started was my,
in my,
with my blog is really good figure.
Start doing a gamble gambler,
watch my blog and uh,
you know,
start just stopped doing
that and getting either,
it's gone really well.
Yeah.
You started this sort of social
media campaign around the same time,
is that what it was?
Social media campaigns?
Yeah.
Well,
the,
the videos,
the blog.
Yeah.
But basically I got
confidence in my writing.
I think I'm a good writer.
I get extra credit because I looked
the way I do and I'm an MMA fight,
so they think,
oh well I forgot and then,
oh,
we can string a sentence together,
you know,
I'll take that extra credit.
Yeah.
No,
it's fun riding you.
You,
you have fun with it and it's cool.
Colossal concerns.
It's called,
right?
Yeah.
Colossus concerns.
I've got my website,
colossus concerns and where,
where they,
uh,
where can they get it?
What is the muscle website?
I've got a website.
It's the colossal collective.com.
So it's colossal concerns,
not colossus concern.
Oh yeah.
I always kept that long.
My message goes every fucking time.
Huh?
Constantly.
Ivy fucking video.
I've done well.
Everything.
We got it right.
I go,
so what did I say?
Colossal collective.com.
That's where my blogs and my podcast,
no,
that's my blog.
Totally won't place colossal.
Collect this way.
Say I'm looking at right now it's
colossal concerns that college collect of
collective collective has everything
you'd get like a collective.
That's what they tell the bank.
Yeah,
I guess,
right?
It is about,
I'm yourself,
right?
No,
no,
definitely.
I,
you feel like I'm in Japan.
They had a different attitude towards
people winning and losing all anywhere
else in the world and my culture.
Yeah.
So tell me why I Samurai fighting spirit.
My first fight.
It's a fucking joke.
Vanita costs of and got a guy,
you know,
knock him over and he kicks my ass.
It's a fucking joke.
But what did they appreciate depreciate
that I fucking gave it everything and it
was something different and
in America and the joke,
okay.
But they gave me another
chance to Japanese and our one,
my next couple of fights and that
gave me a chance to keep going.
Preach you guys.
Yeah.
It,
well,
it's fascinating that you've
seen both ends of the spectrum.
You seen the Co,
the Japanese way of doing things where
you respect the people who show warrior
spirit and try and then you seen American,
you've got to get you to the hospital.
We got to get you to the hospital.
James Thompson has got to the hospital.
Apparently he's almost dead.
Almost beat him to death
and he's wearing Meghan's.
Yeah.
You have a campaign against skinny jeans.
Is that what it is?
Oh,
well it's men's fashion as a whole
managed fashion as a whole fucking alpha.
Now what the Alpha nail is created by
the people it was originally created by
the people that do on it.
Yeah,
I know people that do it.
Sorry I'm,
I made fun of him constantly.
Well listen,
the guy,
Aubrey,
well I'm a business with is an awesome
dude and it's a lot of guys in MMA wore
makeup or nail Polish,
which is the essentially makeup.
I mean it is.
Yeah.
I mean it's makeup,
it's nail Polish bits,
Manga.
What are you,
what are you doing?
And he was not as I call your toes.
Did you pay them that color?
Don't Clark.
Yeah,
that's what they say.
But some guys actually do have like,
I think frank twig might've been the
one that started out and he had like
problems with his toenails.
I don't believe that you think you just
like take Fletcher used to always have
his guys did it.
It was a thing that happened for a while
when MMA sort of was like starting to
pop and some guys still do it.
I noticed it and fights.
It's some guys still their toenails
painted guys can be whatever they want.
But I did,
I did this and obviously
it's tongue and cheek,
but you know,
people come with whatever
the fuck they won't buy it.
Do you think men's fashion?
Yeah.
And what we're saying what you did,
there's a video.
It's man against Megan's,
right?
That's,
yeah.
It's pretty funny,
man.
You take the matings
off and your burn them.
Um,
is that like those leggings pants had
like round the light for vaguely like
fucking tight for men,
but the and stuff like
what do you call a Megan's?
That's the clever fuck.
Oh,
right.
The men wear them on the street.
They walk around with them on.
They're not,
you're not talking about the gym,
right?
No,
because there's a lot of guys wear them.
They'll get the cat because I am,
I am making him at the end of
the video being comfortable.
It's fine.
And he didn't show up.
I'll come on.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a good look for you.
I don't know why you're not embracing it.
So you take that battle.
Ram,
where did these guys,
when they have these banking's,
what do they,
um,
what do they put their
like wallet and Shit?
That's a good question.
Joe.
No fanny pack or scared maybe.
Maybe that's the next step.
I'm not scared of a fanny pack.
I wear a fanny pack the airport.
Yeah,
I do all the time and I still do.
People see me with one.
They go,
are you serious?
Yeah,
I'm fucking terrified.
Fanny packs or where it's at.
If you're not trying to get laid
and you just carry shit around,
what do you care?
Why?
Why wouldn't you put a
fanny pack on Megan's?
It sounds like you function begins.
No,
that's where I draw the line because
that's where we need to draw that line.
But if you are a want to let
everybody know that you're gay,
where the makings like it's a good move.
I would say if you're a gay guy,
you know you're letting
people know what's up.
I'm the fucking ass cheeks.
Nothing wrong with that.
That's what they're like.
Don't you like that girls with Yoga Pants?
They like it to your cock.
Cox All plaster the side
of your come up Megan leg
till I got a light blue and the ocean
blue like something you might see in the
the bay in Hawaii.
A Nice,
delicious light blue.
Megan's with your cock.
Three quarters hard pinned to the side
of your leg going about belly button
piercing.
Get Dude with a belly button piercing.
Suspect number one.
Hey,
who blew those people?
Is that a guy with a belly button ring?
Let's talk to him.
All right,
James Thompson.
Yep.
It's been a fun time man.
I mean Johnny Mate,
I was doing a bit of that wheel.
It's been great.
It's been fantastic.
Best of luck to you,
man.
If you ever need us to promote anything,
you want to get anything out there and
you want to come back and do it again.
Want to tell some more stories?
Hey Jay,
closest 12th so Jay Colossus,
Twitter.
I'm James the Closest Thompson,
far Facebook but colossal concerns.
No cool looking colossal concerns.
If you're looking for the blog,
cultural collective,
colossal,
collective.com colossal
concerns is the blog j colossus.
That's how I,
that's me.
That is you on Twitter.
Okay.
So,
and what are you on Grindr.
Oh,
I've got to give a
fuck.
You son of a bitch.
You got,
what else would you have to say?
I can't remember.
Oh,
what do you stand about?
Brain damage.
About what?
It's not good for you.
No thoughts.
Makes a gamble.
Uh,
thanks to Tim for hooking us up.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save 25 bucks
off any device and or service and an
ethical cell phone company
that you can get behind.
Thanks also to audible.com
audible.com forward slash Joe,
go there.
Get yourself a free audio book.
I recommend the disaster
diaries by my friends,
Sam Sheridan.
It's excellent.
And it's available for free to you if you
do this because you get one free audio
book.
So,
uh,
go check it out.
And a sign up.
You get one free month,
one free audio book,
audible.com forward slash Joe,
go to on at.com o n n I t
use the code named Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off
any and all supplements.
Go there and get your freak on.
All right,
folks,
we will see you,
uh,
next while we'll see you.
Next show will be tomorrow with,
um,
powerful Brian Cowen.
And then we also have a show
with Dana white on Thursday.
And then Friday night we got
the comedy show with mad flavor,
who is also known as Joey
motherfucking Diaz and me.
And we will be at the grove in Anaheim.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
you can find out all the ticket
information and that's it freaks.
We love the shit out of you and we'll
see you tomorrow and we appreciate you
very much.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Ooh.